this is jocko podcast number 326 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening
throughout october 30th and 31st 2011
in furtherance of the drug enforcement
administration's drug law enforcement
mission in afghanistan special agents of
the dea's foreign deployed advisory
support
or fast team
conducted counter-narcotics
counterinsurgency operations with their
police partners from the afghan national
interdiction unit
assisted by the australian defense
forces the task force departed their
base via four helicopters as part of a
mission to execute afghan
drug warrants
and to search for narcotics caches and
heroin production labs
the team began to search the target area
and accompanying
opium bazaar
when they began to receive sporadic
incoming enemy fire
they accomplished their assigned duties
and then maneuvered to the extraction
location all wall under sporadic enemy
fire
when the task force arrived at the
helicopter landing zones they continued
to receive effective enemy fire one of
the four helicopters was forced to make
an additional orbit and subsequently
land in the vicinity of special agents
piersante johnson vanderbilt harris
stewart fisher portinga and five members
from the australian special forces
this helicopter landed under fire
special agent persone laid down
suppressive fire
which enabled special agent stuart
harris and fisher to board the
helicopter once inside special agent
stewart continued applying suppressive
fire special agent stewart directed an
afghan door gunner to initiate
suppressive fire in an attempt to
cover the remaining members of the team
still outside the helicopter
special agent pasante was approximately
10 meters from the rear of the
helicopter
when he was hit by enemy fire
the round penetrated his ballistic
helmet
entered above his right eye and exited
above his left eye and he was
immediately rendered unconscious and
fell to the ground
special agent portinga
positioned himself at the rear of the
helicopter and continued laying down
suppressive fire as special agent
persante
was being brought back into the
helicopter
he instinctively put himself in harm's
way and return fire until all personnel
were on board the helicopter as the
helicopter took off special agents
vanderbilt johnson and harris
immediately rendered first aid to
special agent persante and controlled
his bleeding maintained an open airway
and stabilized him
special agent persante was eventually
transferred to the veterans affairs
medical center in richmond virginia for
continued treatment and rehabilitation
the actions of all agents
involved both before and following the
shooting were very clearly heroic
and that right there was an excerpt from
an article
by the u.s department of justice who
oversees
the dea
and special agent joseph prisante
survived that round to the head
he became the first ever member of the
dea to receive the secretary of defense
medal for the defense of freedom
and also received the federal
congressional badge of bravery
but
that bullet
did do significant damage most
significantly it rendered special agent
persante blind
but
he has continued to drive on to grow to
teach
and set an incredible example of
perseverance for all of us
it is an honor to have him here with us
tonight to share some of his experiences
and lessons learned joe
thanks for coming on man you're quite
welcome first i want to say it's an
honor to be part of this podcast and i
was very flattered that you guys asked
me to be on it
well you're the first dea guy we've got
here so you got another first under your
belt now
but you didn't start off in the d let's
let's like i like to go back to the
beginning let's figure out where you
came from how you ended up being who you
are
uh
born in detroit right
yes
actually grew up was born and raised in
the city of detroit my dad was a police
officer there
and at the time there was residency so
we had to live in a city i'm actually
third generation
law enforcement officer
in my family when you say there was a
residency what do you mean by that you
have to live in the city you had to live
in the city to be a police officer yes
or any at the time any city workers wow
if you're a fire uh fighter or you know
work for the city sanitation things like
that you have to live in the city so we
all kind of clustered and huddled in
little areas
and and your dad was a cop
his whole career that was what he did
yes um he retired um in detroit 1990
then went on to
work at the university of michigan their
police department eventually became
chief of police there
so did you have aspirations of being a
cop as well
yes um
you know growing up i always played team
sports i was fortunate enough to
play college and football at a smaller
school in southern michigan and i always
liked that kind of team atmosphere
and my father he worked conspiracy
narcotics for years and years in detroit
police department
and i just saw that kind of team
environment team atmosphere
and it kind of drew me to it
even though my father never pushed me to
go into law enforcement
and actually when i went away to college
my major at first was sports medicine i
wanted to be an athletic trainer and
then the more i thought about i'm like
you know what i really want to do this
law enforcement thing
so i talked to my dad and he's like okay
you know i support you
and if you're going to do the law
enforcement
he worked on a dea task force
um in a a drug task force there and he
says you know i would encourage you to
go federal
just because
the pay is a little better you get to
travel the world and you get to see and
do a lot of things and
i've always been a been a kind of rough
tumble person and dea has always been
known as the kind of blue collar federal
law enforcement
so he kind of tried to push me that way
and he had friends that still worked
there
but unfortunately when i graduated from
college in december of 91 dea was on a
hiring freeze
so i went back home to the detroit
michigan area and
detroit police was hiring so i put my
application there and got hired
by the detroit police department in
february of 1993.
now now when you say you were a rough
and tumble kid
to me it seems like when i talk to
people that had police's parents they
they're either like really good on the
straight and narrow or they're kind of
rebellious where where were you at were
you were somewhere in the middle
yeah you know i kind of had a rebellious
streak to me but luckily i had a strong
father and a strong grandfather
and kind of kept me um
on the straight
and narrow and my father was pretty
tough on me
and but he always supported me he always
went to my athletic events was there all
the time
you know he
you know
would put a foot up my ass if i needed
but also you know was very loving and
support you know i could still call my
father today hey dad i need help he's
like okay
i'm on the way and
a little more background um my dad's
father
and actually my mother's father they
both both served in world war ii
and my dad's father he actually landed
in omaha beach on d-day
and the second wave and later got a
silver star pushing through germany
um
when you did you have brothers and
sisters i have one sister she's four
years younger than me
but you were kind of the only son so
your dad was
at every sporting event that there was
oh yes and he coached me every sport but
football
um so
but to always even at grade school
um he would video my games at the old
vhs video cameras and we sit down and
watch the games after
with him and he'd be like you know joey
you know they called me my daddy's name
is joe too and my both grandfathers were
joe so they called me joey joey you did
this wrong you did that wrong my mom
would be like leave that poor kid alone
hey were you how were you in school were
you did you feel like you had to do good
in school because your dad was kind of
keeping an eye on you yeah you know i
felt you know that i needed to do you
know well in school
ham
school
things
i would say i have you know i'm i know
what you're trying to say yeah you know
you know i'm i'm a pretty athletic guy
but i've always had to work work in life
for things you know i was taught you
work hard you put the effort in and if
you didn't succeed at something you go
back and look at it and you kind of
become kind of analyze yourself okay
what did i do right what did i do wrong
what can i do better i've had a good
example
to you know put hard work in
you know and most often hopefully it's
gonna pay off
and um
i just had a good example that way and
you played you played college football
as well yes you said
and you
how was that how was that did you guys
win a lot did you lose a lot what
lessons you take away from playing
college ball you know i tell you what i
tell everybody sports teaches a lot of
lessons in life
teaches you how to win how to lose
how to be a team player all those things
and i learned valuable lessons from
sports now in college
i went to a small school in southern
mission called adrian college
we were the most winningest football
team in michigan in the 80s all
divisions
so we did really well when i was there
we won two league championships and
actually went to the division three
college national playoffs in
so it was a good you know i was able to
get my education and
um i excelled in college and football
i knew i wasn't going to be the tallest
guy you know bless my mom she's only
like five foot
so i better be strong and fast so that's
when i picked up the weights and
kind of blew up
as soon as i started lifting so in
college i was an all-league player twice
i was team captain team mvp
um in our league we had uh every week
they listed offense and defensive player
of the week i made that defensive player
of the week numerous times
so you know it was it was good
experience you know you you get the bond
with those you know the people you play
with and you learn life lessons and
actually in college you know you finally
get to do things you know classes that
you're interested in your major and i
did really well in college and actually
in my major i had over a three point
average and stuff so and you said you
transferred or you switched from being
in
want to be go become like an athletic
trainer into
what sociology criminal justice what so
you made the decision hey i'm gonna go
go be a cop or something like that yes
after after my freshman year
yeah at the time at our school we didn't
have a
just specific criminal justice program
so it was sociology with the emphasis on
criminal justice and
i
continued sports medicine as my minor
degree
so then you get done with that the
federal the dea is not hiring as you
said and so now you
decide you're going to go and become a
detroit cop yes
is it hard to apply for how strict is it
was it easy to get into did you third
generation did you just get like a
welcome mat at the front door to get in
there i wouldn't say that when i showed
the recruiter you know it was like you
know they didn't give me any cut me any
slack at all you know you got to go take
your little eye test and this and that
and you know you go through the process
of course it's not as
intense and as detailed as a process
getting hired federally because you have
to get security clearance you know but i
you know they do a good job and
you know i had decent credentials and
you know
luckily i just
didn't get in a lot of trouble or didn't
get caught so i didn't have bad things
on my record
so you know i got in fairly easy and
showed up there and
went through the academy and um
i'm not only a kind of a muscle head guy
but i'm fairly intelligent and i
graduated top academically in my class
and got this lamp of knowledge um plaque
and stuff a little genie lamp on there
you know i say
no great shakes you know
my
[Music]
i guess my competition there wasn't as
at the greatest level as the dea um
academics
but um it was pretty good you know you
get to teach a lot a lot to learn a lot
of things and
in detroit i grew up there all my life
so i kind of knew what i was getting
into and
detroit on the police department is kind
of a bat tips in my fire
um you get to learn how to be the real
police real fast
you know it's kind of sink or swim and
and do you immediately just go right out
being like a beat cop in the street
somewhere um what they did is they took
the top people out of our class
and put us in this unit called tactical
service section
we were
a city-wide
unit
that did crowd control
also if there was a barricaded gun
person we would do outer perimeter
and we would work in areas where they
were having problems certain precincts
or the precincts got overrun with calls
and we would go
in flood to area and help the precincts
out
so it was kind of like a
almost like a qrf like a quick reaction
for us kind of like that in a way
you know but you know we just um
answer the priority one and two calls
like the shots fired things like that
robberies and progress
we took a little those higher level
calls
so it was pretty crazy and
detroit's kind of a weird animal like i
grew up on the east side
so i mostly was the east side guy
and when i became in tss we worked the
whole city so you might be in a couple
different areas or a couple different
precincts as they call it in one day
so where i grew up if i got out and
chased somebody jumped a couple of
fences i knew where the hell i was
and i'll be on the west side bail out
and i was pretty fast and i could jump
fences pretty good so i could usually
catch a lot of people and i was in shape
so i jump a couple fences i'd be in a
yard
holding a suspect at gunpoint and i
wouldn't know where the hell i was at
i'd be like radio tac three i'm a couple
blocks east of my original location
um next to the burned burned-out garage
but the problem was like every third
garage is burned out so
so that was the day-to-day
so you did that right out of the academy
that seems like a strange thing to take
someone that's brand new and put them in
that kind of situation where you're
going into these tough calls all the
time out of the gate that's trial by
fire oh yes but
which was good is a lot of the better
officers worked there at tactical
service section so you got to be trained
and learn from some of the better police
officers
so you know you really got to learn the
job fast and from some good individuals
like how many people were on the team
did you guys show up in like a freaking
armored truck or
well each shift we had we ran two shifts
a day shift
and then a power shift the power shift
was seven and night to three in the
morning those are like the busiest times
day shift and power shifts
so we roll after eight to ten cars okay
two people in a car
you know so we would flood an area so it
was good if you needed backup you needed
help
you know somebody usually was there
fairly fast
but it was it was intense and then after
at the time my dad finished up
he was on the full-time swat team in
detroit
and was crazy about detroit of being a
big city they didn't have a full-time
swat team until 1986.
which to me kind of blows my mind yeah
that's crazy and he was on he was one of
the original members on the team and
then after three years
of working a patrol type unit you could
apply for a special unit or bureau
they call them also and i
tried out for the swat team and later
made the swat team and my last year on
the job i was on the full-time tactical
team which was
you know pretty pretty intense you got
to do a lot of fun stuff and you didn't
have to do a lot of paperwork but
usually the sergeant of the team you
know he did the write up after the
barricaded gun person or unless you got
into of course a shooting you would have
to do a report and
so so you went right from that tactical
service section
into the swat team yes how many years
did you did you do the the tackle
service section three years and then one
year on the full-time swat team and then
did you shoot any did you fire your shot
should fire your weapon at all during
those three years with the tactical
service
not with tss but on the swat team and it
took a while to get hired by dea
you know government sometimes it's hurry
up and wait and um
i was sitting around i didn't hear
anything that i had failed something and
time went by months went by and i get a
call and they're like mr persona you
still interested in a job but dea i said
of course i am yeah um we had lost your
application we found it now oh man i'm
like this is has every information about
me you know parents siblings every
neighbor i've ever had you know that
i've had and
the the um process kind of really sped
up so i'm like
three months out from the academy and we
go to a barricaded gunman
and one of the precincts in detroit and
it's an ex-military person they have
kind of mental problems and they would
hold the neighborhood and their family
at bay of shooting at them
every so often so we respond and
we begin take over from the precinct
begin negotiating with them and
they start shooting at our armored
personnel carrier through the window and
it's starting to ramp up
and
we had some officer stations in the
backyard and the person goes out and
you know exchanging
shooting at them but they don't have a
clear shot at the suspect
and they had a car in the driveway
and my team was on a break we were like
four or five houses down in between
houses
and we had um one of the suburbans we
had
with us and we had like half our gear on
and they're like do not let them get
mobile we feel they're trying they're to
might try to go for the car
and then sure is crap
they go for the car
so i jump in the passenger side of the
suburb my buddy drives it jumps in the
driver's seat we're like half dressed
we just got our mp5 sub machine guns
strapped around us
so we pull behind the car to try to
block them in and they start to ram us
and we're like oh crap and by this time
it was dark and then i see a muzzle
flash
through the rear window and they start
shooting at us
so i um
exited the vehicle tactically and my
partner did and
we opened up into the car and
unfortunately had to
dispatch the person and i was like
waiting all this time for dea and then
finally i get in a shooting but think
you know thank god it was a good
shooting i didn't you know there was no
drama with that but i was just like just
my luck you know wait all this time and
then i get in this you know critical
incident
how often were you guys as a swat team
doing hits
you know it varied sometimes in a month
we
four or five times would be maybe a bear
get a gun person
sometimes we would serve
like felony warrants for more dangerous
individuals
once in a while we go out with narcotics
if they were hitting a spot which they
deemed was pretty dangerous
and needed a little more trained units
so we'd go
and do that but you know did a lot of
training tactical training a lot of
shooting
you know and as you can attest to the
more you shoot the more proficient you
know it's kind of a perishable skill
so you know we got to do all those type
of things so it was it was a good
experience
and you were just sporting that 1990s
mp5
yes nine millimeter
yeah i was like oh yeah you're in a
vehicle and you have an mp5 and i'm
you know in the in the 90s for me in the
seal teams you know we used the mp5 and
we thought it was cool until we had to
shoot somebody that was more than you
know 50 yards away and all of a sudden
you think this is not a good weapon to
have no or they have a ballistic vest
it's not going through it yeah you know
and the a-pillar in cars we'll stop that
nine millimeter too yeah
yeah that's uh i guess we've all
transitioned away from the the mp5 now
uh but damn that's an accurate easy to
shoot weapon i think that's like
sometimes people ask me about home
defense weapons like for
like for a female maybe and i think man
an mp5 is not a bad call you're in the
house you're only gonna shoot someone
that's in the house most likely
you know so i think it's and it's so
easy to shoot so accurate yes but you
know you know there's very very little
to almost no recoil on that weapon yeah
and with a suppressor on them it's
nothing
nothing um
but that's a lot of experience that you
had
i mean just doing hits all the time in
the 90s just that kind of experience i
remember from the seal perspective in
the 90s you know we looked at swat teams
especially you know city
big urban center swat teams
you guys were doing you guys were doing
work all the time so the experience that
you all had and i you know we would work
with la swat from time to time
seals would work with la swat and it was
we were kind of
we were kind of envious of the fact that
they got to go out and do the job and
and you know it's the same thing for you
up there in detroit in the 90s you just
if you're in the military in the 90s
chances were you weren't doing anything
real yeah you know so
you getting that experience is
that's a lot of experience to have
um
in the 90s from that perspective
uh so meanwhile you get done with that
you spend that this year so how long
were you on the swat team for
about a year a year on the swat team and
that's and you got picked up for the dea
after three months of being
at the swat team is that what you said
no i was there a little longer but it
just took um i got in that fatal
shooting right three months before um i
was ready to start my academy date
for the academy i i i got hired with dea
in june of 1997.
and and this was you like the dea
because they're and i actually never
heard that the dea was the blue collar
of the feds i like that i didn't know
that before that's the reputation that
they have huh
[Music]
at the time you know things have you
know things are changing in law
enforcement now and everything and but
at the time we were kind of the rough
necks
so to speak
so you get
you get to go to what is it they have
the dea academy
is that what they have yes it's in was
in in quantico virginia um inside the
quantico military base
and when i went through
us and the fbi shared the same academy
we since have our own academy that's
right next to the fbi fbi academy but we
still share the gun ranges
um and driving track and gym with the
fbi
and how long is that pipeline
you know it's like um
like 16 18 week academy
and what are you doing is it legal is it
physical is it what are you doing it's a
little bit of everything um where the
police academy was more paramilitary dea
was more gentleman academy you know
you'd have to line up for inspection
every day i see a speckable lint on your
you know your uniform and getting you
know the front lean and rest position
and all that jazz
but it was very intense very um
academically challenging
um very physically challenged
challenging we did a lot of shooting a
lot of tactical training a lot of
scenarios
i was um very impressed with it the
biggest thing was you're away from your
family for four months
as opposed when i went to detroit police
academy
it wasn't an overnight thing you come
and go and stuff but it was a very
very intense academy
and then when i went through the dea
you couldn't go back to where you were
hired from
they had this thing with our
administrator who's the person who runs
dea
you couldn't go back because there might
be
potential for corruption
and to me in my if you're going to be
corrupt you're going to be corrupt
wherever you go
true so
we um
you know three quarters of the academy
they put a list out
and the different spots opened and you
know say you got 50 individuals in your
academy class and there's 50 spots and
of course it's where individuals are
needed and of course dea with the drugs
coming from mexico a lot of border spots
so i'm like well i don't speak spanish
so maybe i won't have to go there
um a lot of spots in new york la you
know big cities like that
and you get to pick your top three
choices
you're not guaranteed necessarily to get
any one of those and you can work it out
with the class you know you get to sit
there beforehand and okay there's so
many spots here who wants to put in for
one of these spots and you can kind of
work it out and you submit your top
three
and like i said you're not guaranteed to
get them
any of those spots and if you speak
spanish and there's some
border spots you're probably gonna go to
the border and
hi um
so what'd you put for your top three
slots that you wanted i put phoenix
arizona
i'm number one i had never been to
phoenix but
was gonna have to move and i was married
at the time and
my wife had at the time had dual custody
with her children she's two boys young
boys
and she's gonna have to move away from
them so i kind of let her pick
and then i put
fort lauderdale in miami i was i had
being from michigan i had a lot of
family that lived
vacation seasonally in florida in the
winter months but i also had a
grandmother
that had a place in arizona and then my
wife at the time had a grandfather that
lived there so
put in for phoenix arizona and
as long as you weren't like a butt head
and this and that and you you know you
you more or less got one of your top
three spots so i was very fortunate
in that so i got that
selected and got phoenix
and then um so what do you do when you
show up you're a new guy are you a new
guy they call you a new guy what do they
call you oh yeah they're kind of you
know
effing new guy you know all kind of
stuff you know
and um so
i find out that i'm going to show up
there i'm going to the clandestine
clandestine laboratory task force group
we're going to be doing meth labs
now from detroit i've never seen
methamphetamine one time really
but it's not really an
urban city drug um
um
that's kind of more of a white trash
drug per se you know in the city you
know you have heroin or they call it a
city heron
and um of course cocaine crack cocaine
marijuana and things like that so i just
leave the academy and they're like joe
you're going back to the academy for
clan labs go i'm like oh [__]
so i got stuck in the um the clan lab
group for my first four years but it was
kind of good because it was a local task
force
ran out of the the maricopa county
sheriff's office
and
you got to learn the basics of narcotics
investigations
how to write search warrants how to deal
with informants
which is kind of our bread and butter
and you get to learn the job so
it really taught me how to become
a dea
investigator
and i would say on the low end of the
estimate i've been in at least 500
methamphetamine lamps
and we really you know we're wearing all
the protective gear in it but really
don't know what the long term exposures
to
all these caustic and hazardous
chemicals are
i i
had a neighbor whose nephew um
got involved in meth
and
he told me he had been to prison and he
got out of prison
and when i met him the nephew had gotten
out of prison and i met him and was
talking to him and he was yeah i was i
was just got out of prison he said and
he told me he said when i tried crystal
meth for the first time as soon as i
tried it i realized that was the only
thing i ever wanted to do for the rest
of my life was more crystal meth and he
stole everything from his mom everything
was her grandma everything from his
uncle
everything from all of his friends
[Music]
ruined every relationship in san diego
and then
went to somewhere else san bernardino
and made friends there and stole from
all them and then did that all across
the country until he finally wound up in
texas and
you know that's where he finally got
rolled up and sent to prison but that
that meth thing is freaking crazy huh no
it's crazy you know you know these drugs
are crazy especially these harder drugs
like as just kind of said he controls
their whole life
you know and
most of the labs are smaller we call
them mom and pop labs or cooking ounces
that's cute you know you know it's um
they make enough to get their own for
free and you know and
sell a little bit to their friends you
know so they get theirs for free and you
know they're cooking in these houses
with these little kids
you know and everything is off gassing
into the you know into the air getting
into the carpet and walls and everything
else
so we started bringing child protective
services with us when we would do
methamphetamine lab warts
and they would bring the kids to the
hospital
and when they would test them
you know a high percentage of them would
test positive for methamphetamine just
because the stuff you know was in the
carpet in the atmosphere you know it
just breaks my heart you know me having
a daughter you know these little kids
involved and then not only would they
get charged with the meth lab and
manufacturing they would get charged
with child abuse from cps also
so you would do these investigations
your your
get are you getting human intelligence
that's telling you hey i get my i get my
meth from this person over here then you
find out where that person lives then
you track them for a little while figure
out you know where they're doing
suspicious activity and then you do a
hit on it how does that work
yes that's one of the means with an
informant hey you know
you know informants you know some are
trying to work off charges some are just
paid informants and they go around and
that's what they do
you know so-and-so's manufacturing meth
here you know i saw
you know these classware items i saw
this part of the cooking procedure i saw
these chemicals
you know and then you do
you know some more background and then
you do you know some investigation
surveillance and use kind of some of our
techniques that we use
to you know
kind of make sure and validate the
informant
and we also get information from
different places to sell these chemicals
you know joe blow is buying you know
keeps buying every month so many pounds
of red phosphorus so many pounds of
iodine crystals or the different stores
when you could
buy the coal pills the pseudophedrine or
ephedrine tablets over the counter
they would kind of some stores would
work with us
and they would get license plates
so we'd do a workup
and um you know find out where these
people lived and started an
investigation and then we got enough
probable cause for a search warrant we
would hit these locations
you know because of the
the dangers of meth labs a lot of times
you don't know what the atmosphere was
so you when you rated it you would have
to go in with full
scba self-contained breathing apparatus
because you didn't know what the
environment and oxygen level was in the
houses and of course you got this big
tank on your back and it's
kind of cumbersome and
a lot of local swat teams where
clan lab trained for tactics so there
were some little smaller tactical
bottles you could use so
a lot of unknowns and you know
one of our investigative techniques you
go through and garbage cans when they
put it on the curb so a lot of these
meth people didn't know that we would
pull trash so they would save every bit
of lab trash they ever had in one room
so you're missing you know you're
missing mixing acids and bases together
and things are off-casting so it's not a
very safe environment to say the least
um real quick what's a paid informant
they're actually
almost like a professional informant
because like for money seizure and drug
seizures we would pay them money
so they go around and work
and travel sometimes from city to city
just to make money as an informant
you know and at different times when you
know budgets and we had good money and
you know they got a certain percentage
of a a cash seizure or asset seizure you
know they can make some fairly decent
money and what these are just guys sort
of off the street or do they apply for
that job or it's really you know you you
have to fill out a
package for a person that wants to be a
confidential source of course you have
to run their criminal history
make sure they have no act of warrants
and you know you have to
supervise them pretty tight
and um you know some people get approved
for to work his information some don't
just because their criminal history and
their stuff is just so bad
you know so it's
you know it's a catch-22 you know you
can't get a choir choir person or choir
boy you know to catch people but it's
it's a fine line and you've got you have
to manage it well
and as you're doing this and you say you
went into
over 500 meth labs in how many years was
that
four years four years
so that's like you know a hitting a meth
lab every two or three maybe four days
going into those things
did you feel like
hey there we're making a dent or
sometimes you just feel like we're just
overwhelmed and this is we could keep
doing this forever
it got to the point where
it was bad for a while he almost felt
overwhelmed but there were so many
and it was so easy to get the precursor
chemicals to manufacture methamphetamine
here in the united states
so then we started
as a whole dea we started cracking down
into the companies that
made the
ephedrine tablets or the pseudoephedrine
pills which is one of the primary
precursor chemicals of methamphetamine
and would track where they're shipping
and made them harder to get and that's
why you probably see like if you buy any
cold medication that has pseudoephedrine
you got to buy it you have to get it
from behind the counter now right
because people were going in just you
know buying two stealing two
two boxes and they called it like
smurfing pills and they would get enough
to make you know how much
methamphetamine
they wanted to make
so that started really putting
we saw that started putting a dent into
it
you know and of course you know then
originally
when i was working these labs of course
there's a lot of methamphetamine coming
up from mexico but it wasn't that pure
so a lot of the true tweakers did not
want it they wanted that real pure glass
98 99 you know percent pure
methamphetamine
which was home grown made
and then once the um
we you know cracked down the precursors
and harder to get here
mexico started picking up their game
and started making the real pure
methamphetamine down in mexico and
sending it up through the border so does
that mean you were dealing with the
cartel the big drug cartels
um yes a lot and especially when i
worked in phoenix
you know of course that's what is you
know the southwest is controlled by the
mexican drug cartels
um
do you have any you know big memorable
operations or that you did that you were
part of
yes um
like i said most of the labs were like
mom and pop tweaker labs
but i was able to do
a
couple of pretty big we call a mexican
national labs
where they're making multiple multiple
pounds at one time
and
the sheriff's office had some
information
that they had a couple guys came in and
they wanted to work for money and they
knew of this big mexican national lab
west
of phoenix in an area called whispering
ranch
you know we're like okay i went with a
guy i went with another partner to see
what they have to say you know a lot of
times a lot of things can be bs and
people over hype and over blow it up
you know so we go out there and you know
hey this is group of these mexican
nationals you know they're making you
know 30 40 50 pounds of math at a time
they're cooking out
in this real rural location
you know so
we get a workup and start doing some
investigation
and identify where the people are living
in the city and we have an informant
that's willing and knows when they're
out there cooking
you know so we're building up a plan and
you know of course it's on the middle of
nowhere so there's no address of this
place there's a parcel number so you're
getting like a gps grid coordinates to
hit this place and that's what's uh
the search warrant and you know you know
how we're gonna hit this place into
cooking are we gonna do an air assault
what are we going to do
so we finally it got up in um
got close okay they said they're going
to cook this weekend and what's the time
frame on all this like how long does
this take
is it is it weeks is it days is it
months it all depends it varies i think
this one in particular
um i think we were working on it for a
couple months
so the informant says i think they're
going to cook this weekend i said okay
we'll we'll get ready so
you know we're preparing and getting you
know as much information as we have
typed up in the search warrant and
everything and we knew there was a a
property close to them which the guy was
kind of involved and
if they were going to run from the lab
location
they
more than likely they were going to go
hide at their rest that residence
you know so the informant calls me okay
they're going out and buying a bunch of
ice
so one of the processes of cooking meth
at the end you got to start adding ice
to things and cool it down so we knew
okay they're cooking
they're almost they're getting close to
done
so we spin up the team we put an
affidavit what the
the informant says and we get it signed
by a judge and
we were working with the sheriff's
office at the time and
it was decided we're not going to do an
air assault we're going to convoy in
there and
you know this is a rural location and on
your convoy you know in a desert type
environment you're kicking up dust and
stuff they can see you coming from five
miles away how big of a team are you
bringing and this is like an assault
team yeah we're bringing the um
the um
the maricopa county swat team you know
it's probably 20 something individuals
our lab team you know we probably got
10 individuals or so and then we're
bringing chemists and
hazmat and everything out so it's a
pretty good force big convoy big convoy
a lot of dust up
so of course um the plan was the swat
team was going to hit the lab location
do you put a recon element out at all or
did you do ariel or nothing
we had an aerial prior but we didn't
have time to to get people light in
there late in there to do it we would
have liked that to happen but it just
wasn't feasible with the situation
so of course the swat team hits it hey
we got a huge lab up cooking but
nobody's here
they're like oh [__]
so
the group that i was with we go to you
know we so wait let me catch that so the
swat team hits it they find the lab and
there's no people there yes it's up and
cooking oh man
okay
so
like i i said earlier i said if they run
they're probably going to go to this
other gentleman's house
so we go to that house and
um
we hear some noise and some scurrying in
the house and
we hear like a lady like
calling for help
so we're like damn they're in there
so agnes circumstances we enter the
house
and they're all trying to hide in this
back bedroom got one guy's halfway up
the chimney
the other guy's lying in bed with his
muddy boots and everything out like he's
sleeping and laying on the couch and i'm
like really guys
we're gonna fall for this so we we
brought them back over to the lab and
you know processed the lab and ended up
being a
nice-sized lab they think they had like
50 pounds of methamphetamine in solution
and then that later led to
they end up cooperating and then hit
another big lab in south phoenix and
that individual
he also was running labs and
riverside california too
so he was wanted you know by riverside
sheriff and this and that and we ended
up hitting them and
getting a um
a big lab at that time and we make entry
with the swat team and that's this guy
was living on a horse property at horses
and stuff wait where was this this guy
was in phoenix as well yeah the phoenix
area yeah south phoenix actually so this
guy was a legit
like he had horses and a ranch of some
kind oh yeah this guy was doing well and
had a ranch in um
riverside too yeah because i kind of get
the impression you know when you talk
about like the mom and pop labs
that a lot of people are just kind of
getting away with what they can and then
they eventually get busted yeah and
they're broken but occasionally you have
somebody that broke us the joke these
people they they're in it for making the
money
and um yeah it's um this guy who we hit
um in south phoenix he actually taught
the other people in the other lab how to
cook
so yeah we we go in there and he's in
the back cooking and
he's cooking with a 22 liter flask big
triple neck flask it's a good size flask
about size of a basketball a little
bigger so when the swat team goes in he
takes the flask and smashes it on the
ground
you know but of course you take the
samples there you know he's not gonna
you know hit we figure out what's in
there and
so yeah any you know we found some you
know
methamphetamine in the house and
everything we're like what's this oh
that is feed for the horses and that's
not feed for the damn horses come on
what happens to these guys you go then
you wrap them up
they immediately go to jail you wrap
them up he went to the latin to jail you
know they did some search warrants on
his place in riverside in california and
then we indicted him and you know put
him in prison for a while how long is a
while like this guy his name was tara
thomas to harold sanchez i think he got
like 10 years
so he's probably out but he's probably
listening to this right now
yeah probably perhaps you know you know
but this lab oh hell this is back in
this one um i think 99.
so
yeah for sure yeah he's back out
you know i forgot to ask you this when
you got in that shooting back when you
were with the detroit what did you have
any lessons learned from that about the
way it happened about what you what how
your reaction was did you do something
well did you do something bad do you
feel like your training work did you
feel like your training didn't work like
how was that experience
that yes that's a very good question
with all the training we had
you know the different scenarios and
different barricaded gun people i just
reacted with my training
you know i saw the muzzle flash i knew
it was gunfire
and
you know i just
did what i had to do to neutralize you
know to stop the threat
so the training you had worked
you know i didn't even think you know i
didn't even don't even remember looking
through my sights i know i did
you know you get that perceptual
narrowing you know when you're in a
fight or flight or a gunfight you know
where your eyesight increases your
hearing decreases you start
so you see five motor skills so you felt
all that stuff yes what about the you
you were the passenger and another guy
was driving yes did he get hit or was he
okay no he was okay he um he fired like
four or five shots and
i had my mp5 on full automatic and i
just fired bursts until the weapon ran
dry
damn going full auto huh
yeah i was like hey um i'm going to end
this as quick as possible yeah you know
you people get all these you know lucky
shots you know you're chasing these
you know perpetrators whatever and
they're running from you and and they
take the gun and shoot it over their
head and hit you you know dead between
the eyes yeah
yeah
uh
what about doing all these you know
doing all these hits over the years with
the dea down in the phoenix area you
know you you obviously are starting to
pack away some good some good you know
methodologies and and thought processes
as you're going to do these things like
all your big takeaways
as you
as you developed
as a you know as a agent
i always
was very tactically proficient
and i think one of my fortes and strong
points as an agent was being able to
deal with people and that's what i i
suggest that anybody who gets in federal
law enforcement i would advise them to
be a local law enforcement officer first
but you get to learn the job you get to
learn how to deal with people
and i happen to be very good at dealing
with informants and i could work
informants well what do you think was
that what made you good at it
one i think my street smarts growing up
in detroit you know and being able to
talk to lingle
and look the part you know in life
unfortunately a lot of times
when you first go in a situation
especially criminals they're going to
size you up they're going to say does
this individual look like they know what
they're doing
can i trust this person
you know because a lot of times these
people that are working for us they're
risking their life and they have to feel
confident
that you're going to do your best to
protect them
and i also learned never
promise somebody something you can't
deliver
you know don't promise them well you
know you work a couple weeks and you get
a couple you know i can make all your
charges go away it's not up to it's not
up to the agents you know you have to
bring their cooperation attention to the
prosecutor which then brings it to the
judge and you know those decisions
are made then
and um also treat people like a peep a
person
you know you don't have to start you
know
talking down to somebody you know i'm
the big bad fed and you know you're just
a lowly peon drug dealer you don't do
that
you know i start off giving everybody
respect
now if you want to go sideways we'll go
sideways
but i'm going to give you the benefit of
the doubts
at first
you know in informants too you got to be
careful you know
they're informants they're they're
criminals
you know
you know that they can turn their back
on you too
so you gotta you know you never can
trust them 100 percent you do
your best and you know and
you lay the you know lay the
the ground rules and everything and then
you know you manage your informants
you know
going on from there but you know being
having a good informant you're kind of
like you know they're
they're confident you know there's
therapists everything else you know if
your phone's gonna be ringing in the
middle of the night and your former's
gonna want to talk to you you know
because his girlfriend left them he left
him or he's they're doing this you know
they're you know he thinking about
making a bad you know you need to answer
those calls and a lot of people don't
like to do that but if you
want to do well at the job at a high
level it's kind of things you have to do
you got to put the work in how many
sources would you be running at a time
like how many people would you be
working with how many informants
um usually i kept anywhere
from three to five informants at any one
given time
what does the trajectory of their lives
look like
i mean do they do they end up they just
do that until they eventually get caught
and killed do they do it until they
eventually
you know do something that sends them to
jail do they ever get out of that life
it's kind of a mixture you know some do
it you know they think they're slick and
they're going to play both sides and
they get caught
they go to prison you know some get
killed you know they get found out you
know we do everything we can to protect
their
identity and some do it for a while or
some are you know trying to help their
legal situation or a family member's
situation or just doing it for money
and you know eventually move on and
get on with their lives and get back
into some normalcy
of life you know and when i was
a d agent and a police officer
you know i didn't gauge my success on
how many people i arrested and this and
that
i
gauge my success on how many people did
i help
they get their life together
you know just because a person you know
gets caught up in drugs or some crime
activities it doesn't necessarily mean
they're a bad person you know they made
some bad decisions
so i gauge my success mostly on hey how
many people this year did i help
yeah that's you must start to really uh
understand the way people operate too
especially dealing with all these people
and you're hearing from them all the
time like the insight that you get into
interacting with people
are they they're showing up there most
of them though they do they most of the
informants have some kind of criminal
background and that's how they end up in
this situation most of them do yes
okay
so
at what point or where were you when
september 11th happened
i was
in my house in phoenix getting ready to
go to the gym
because i never knew how long i was
going to work so i always been into
working out and keep myself fit
so i'd get up and work out before work
and i'm sitting there watching the news
and when the first plane hit
said a small plane just hit the world
trade center
so then of course we're all you know
people were glued to the tv
then the second plane hit and they're
like this is not a small plane and
you know of course all the chaos and
everything that went on that day i ended
up going to the gym and
you know work you know
hey you know we don't know where we're
gonna get hit from next you know so it's
all hands on deck and you know
you know you had the plane hit the
pentagon and
rda headquarters is right across the
expressway from there so people who had
office on that side saw the plane smash
into the pentagon and
so if
things were in chaos for a minute like
to say the least and did they
did they start to think about how to
utilize the dea for
immediately trying to assist like the
national effort
did it change i'm saying i guess i'm
asking did it change like your immediate
life your immediate job or was it okay
well we still got to
you know arrest people that are making
meth so you're going to continue doing
that or was it some kind of change what
kind of happened one of the change that
happened pretty fast was
we when we debrief an informant there's
different things you have to put in
there
like different blocks you know what is
the drug
related activity they have known right
now what are the non-drug related
activity and then they started a
terrorist related activity
did you know you know any people doing
terrorist related activities
and being in the clan lab scene
um
a lot of the individuals who sold and
made money out of the ephedrine
in pseudoephedrine
were middle eastern individuals
so of course you know they were like you
know you know get all your middle
eastern informants and see if they have
any terrorist activity
and we had a lot
dea had a lot of middle east you know
with the the drugs and the
pseudo-veterans so
fbi then wanted to come over and started
to brief in our informants you know
about terror terrorist related
activities
was there much of a connection or was it
more that i'm just trying to make money
um there were some you know there were
some you know some were you know sending
money back and
things like that and
you know when the military first went
over to afghanistan
you know we had some intel but we didn't
know you know other you know bin laden
had his training facilities over there
but
when the u.s military went over there
they
surely realized that the
taliban those insurgent groups were
making their money
for their legal terror activities by the
sale and reduction of heroin
and that's one of the first questions i
get why is dui was dea over in
afghanistan
so so the the military
they knew they were not subject matter
experts on that
so that's when they reached out to the
dea hey guys gals we need help here
right
and we didn't have a kind of tactical
team
that was up to speed
to do this at the time
years prior to that we had an operation
called operation snow cap
where we were in columbia and other
cocaine manufacturing destinations
and hitting coca labs you know with you
know partner forces and this and that so
dea had to start up a team so they used
some of the individuals that we worked
in snowcap
and developed this fast team this
foreign deployed advisory support team
to
help the
military
and mentor
our partner force over there because we
really don't have over there
you know any
like criminal authority
so in the afghans they were behind the
time so we went over you know the
military you know they got plenty of
trigger pullers and of course we can
pull triggers too
but they went for expertise on
investigations
how do we handle these how do we process
these labs because in afghanistan even
though heroin production is crazy this
the penalties for
getting caught manufacturing drugs over
there are very very severe
and we can actually take somebody off
the battlefield a lot longer
you know for drug related things than
just for say you know you
you hem somebody up for tactical
questioning and then they're back
directly on the battlefield
you know but the issue is you know we're
working with
u.s and coalition special ops teams over
there because most of these labs are
well behind enemy lines and that's their
money
you know so they're going to fight like
hell to keep them so you have to be up
to speed to run with these you know
these special ops guys
you know so at first they just had to
you know put a solicitation out hey you
know um
this is what the mission is going to be
we need some volunteers you know some of
the guys been that done that in the past
and maybe we're special ops guys but at
the current time maybe they weren't in
the best shape
and
they would get over there and were
having problems keeping up got it so
that's when our fast team
instituted a selection process
and that selection process they took
various
areas of selections from different
special ops teams and put a selection
together
you know
and then and at what point did you hear
about that and at what point did you
volunteer for it
i knew the fast team was going on
you know i started hearing rumbles about
it in
2005 time frame
but the problem is in the field
um
the basic agents didn't really know
what's going on with this fast team i
had a buddy that went to the fast team
he was
a marine corps officer and
i was pushing on with my career and i've
always no matter what i've done
i've tried to
go to the highest level whatever i did
in life
so you know i was just kind of like you
know sitting around and like hey you
know wonder what this fast team's doing
were you still in phoenix at this time
yes i was so you were in phoenix from
like
1997 1998 all so 1997 until
i actually got selected on the fast team
in
october 2009.
so are you there for a while yeah you
have over 10 years experience
as a dea agent on the ground doing and
the was that whole
10 years was that all that time doing
the meth lab stuff the first four years
and then i went on to a conspiracy group
where we were higher level traffickers
i worked on
a task force
with a lot of local officers
when you're what's the conspiracy group
although i mean it sounds cool with that
we know that right
yes yeah exactly a lot of things
government sounds real cool you know and
we have you know real cool acronyms and
everything else you know um you're going
after mid level to higher level dealers
and
still meth mostly
or are they dealing everything meth
cocaine marijuana okay heroin
so you had a mixture so phoenix is kind
of a weird animal you're kind of close
to the border so it's a trans shipment
point
so a lot of the drugs are coming in
coming up from the southwest border into
cities like
tucson and phoenix in their states there
they only stay there a short period of
time and those drugs are picked up
and sent out to the east coast you got
to be like on your game to get stuff
you know because you know you might have
a stash house loaded up one day and it's
gone the next
so you had to really be on your game you
know and move fast to do these things
so you know i worked in a combination of
different groups and
i called my buddy and i'm like hey what
the hell you guys doing there
are you guys just doing training or you
guys going out and doing missions he
goes joe you know we're
you know
working with some of the best units in
the world this is when you're asking
when your buddies about fast yes okay
got it you know what are you guys doing
you know we're training working with
some of the best units in the work world
you know we're doing things what you
would think dea would be doing
you know we're doing this high level
stuff
and at the time
every year they would put out
solicitation force
for
to go through the fast selection
and you need it to be at least gs-12 so
that usually takes about three to four
years
to get to a gs level 12 and they wanted
people who had experience of how to be a
d agent
so you and then you put in for the
selection and if you get picked you know
you go through tryouts and
i was 39 when i put in for selection
you know as we get older we don't
recover as fast as we once did and some
people yes
your potential for injury sometimes
increases so i knew i wouldn't quit
anything i was just worried about my old
body you know holding up i got a lot of
miles on it you know 50 000 miles is
kind of up and
you know it was a lot of different
swimming and different testing and
different things and
you know so i started training and and
you're still doing your job working the
conspiracy
stuff at this time i was on a task force
group
what's the task force group do um we
were
task force on the west side of the city
and we worked with
various west side police departments
and they were all sworn in as
federal task force agents so they had
the full powers like of a dea agent and
you could you know do investigations
over state lines and everything
and we were hitting a lot of like big
marijuana hits meth hits cocaine hits
so i was still yes doing my full-time
job and then have to get ready and train
for the selection
any good between on the conspiracy thing
like what's the biggest people you ever
rolled up
when you were doing the conspiracy gig
we had um one case this one group and
they were
an african-american group they were had
people out of detroit
atlanta
and los angeles and in phoenix
they would get their
large amounts of shipments of marijuana
from
the phoenix and tucson area now we're
talking large amounts i'm talking
they would buy
two
three
thousand pounds of marijuana at a time
and we had it from mexico
yes well they buy it in phoenix the dope
the
marijuana came up from mexico and of
course you buy it and you know
southwest it's a lot cheaper than you
bring it out east and you can sell it
for almost double the price
so there's a lot of money involved we
have an informant you know these guys
are rich and they have this
huge place in this gated community and
scottsdale and all these truckers that
are driving for them and everything
so it's full-on it's a full-on
enterprise
enterprise you know but you you got to
be kind of suspect a little bit you're
like yeah this is a little far-fetched
you know
um
so the informant says okay
they're meeting they're going to meet
their
source of supply and they're going to do
a deal and i'm going to be at the house
so like okay we set up
we have a general area where we think
their nice house is
and so we got some people set up in that
vicinity and they go
into this residence
in phoenix and they pull
a van in the garage we're like okay this
looks good
so
the van leaves the garage and informant
says okay they picked up
so sure as [__] they found a van we take
it this gated community in scottsdale
where you gotta you know get keyed in
and buzzed in and everything and
we um
sit on the house and get it identified
where they're at
and see people coming and going and they
follow them out and sure as [__] they go
to a warehouse too or there's a semi
truck
we're like oh it's on and popping now
so we get enough for
a search warrant
for the house
and the warehouse and hit it and get a
pretty good large amount of of marijuana
and during this time one of the we found
one of the guys and
to the airport and you know we're kind
of short numbers we got people all over
the place
and i'm by myself following this guy and
it's very hard to do surveillance by
yourself
without getting burnt you know without
them seeing you
and i don't know how i pulled it off but
i did
so
what are you wearing
just street clothes just street clothes
ever i don't know just it seems like you
would have a similar issue since you're
uh pretty jacked you know you just stand
out in a crowd yes you know so you just
kind of you know if you were following
me i'm 100 percent gonna know 100 like
there's no you're not gonna sneak around
follow me is not happening yeah on foot
surveillance is very hard you know so
you're in a vehicle you're trying to
stay as far back as you can and
everything and somehow i pulled it off
and as the person got out of
let they let the person out to go into
the terminal i somehow i got one hand
and snapped a photo of him i don't know
how i pulled it off
but i didn't that happened to be the
main guy
so we ended up getting the again i'm
getting a picture of him and we didn't
know you know who he was at the time or
not
and he was flying back to la
you know so we headed and you know get
some people in custody and then get the
person identified
who dropped them off and
she had some prior criminal history
so we knew this case was you know bigger
and tied into all these states and
everything
so i told my partner i said hey
we're going to go visit this lady
um tomorrow and we're gonna bluff her
and we're gonna say hey you know you
know we got you taking this person yada
yada you know and you're
helped in the furtherance of this
conspiracy to their drug trafficking
organization you have some criminal
history in the past you know
you know we're going to potentially look
at indicting you and maybe seize in your
vehicle
and my partner at the time she goes
it'll never work i said watch you're
just trying to get her to roll just get
her to roll i said watch
so we
knock on her door um so so you're
wearing plain clothes plain clothes you
got like a badge around the neck
and a chain you know kind of like tv in
there you wear a t-shirt and a pair of
jeans t-shirt pair of jeans you want to
look as unintimidating as possible do
you want to look intimidating like
what's your what's your
like what's your character what
character you're going into just kind of
at this kind of low-key intimidating
enough with they know your you know
federal law enforcement you know you're
not playing around but you know you're
trying to
you also learn you got to build rapport
with these people too yeah you know to
try to get some common interest and my
partner
at the time your partner was nay saying
this thing will never work she's like i
don't think this will work joe
she was a newer agent
and i said just watch i said watch kim
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
we got like a 50 50 here
let's give it a try and you don't worry
that you're going to give away the fact
that you're on to them
you know at this point you know we
had you know a significant amount of
people in custody okay so you're there
you they know you're on to you know they
know we're on to them at what extent
they don't know
you know but i tell people too you can't
make cases sitting behind your desk all
the time
you got to get out there and shake the
bush
so she's kind of naysaying me and
this person
ended up being a
topless dancer at
one of the gentlemen clubs in phoenix
where
there's a lot of the mexican sources go
hang out there and a lot of the people
from out of town come in there to find
sources
in this person this informant she was
known to date
a lot of these out of town drug dealers
and she would hook them up with the
sources of supply
so we go talk to her and and knock on
the door and
you can tell by her face she's like oh
[__]
and we just lay it out and i said this
is what can happen to you this is okay
i'll cooperate what do you want to know
so we started working with her was wrong
kim was wrong yes
you know so
i you know i guess she didn't get lucky
sometimes and i got lucky then
um so we ended up using her and going
back and
they kept coming to town but of course
they moved their operation to another
spot and then we were able to
investigate and look at all these other
seizures that happened in different
states
and tie them all together to these
people
you know interviewing actually
interviewing the truck drivers got their
sources of supply
you know pulled receipts from hotels and
and plane things at different times when
they
were supposed to do these deals and were
able to tie everything together
and some of these people we had never
caught them red-handed with drugs
but just with testimony by the
informants putting the things together
by pulling receipts
we ended up
hammering this group
and getting them all charged and
indicted when a lot of these other
groups couldn't do it
and i actually helped my partner
get her gs13 was at dea our kind of
journeyman level is gs 13
and you have to do so many things you
know you have to have you know these
complicated cases and or did a wiretap
or did some undercover
so i actually helped kim get her 13 and
i was already on the fast team when they
went and did the takedown but they said
just to see these people's faces like
oh [__]
you got all this on me oh crap and we
used her to do um quite a bit of other
good cases too
did you ever do any undercover work
yes i did some what was that like
um mean everybody thinks it's intense
everybody thinks that you need to look
like a drug addict do undercover
now kind of the contrary like at dea
we're dealing
with people are to make money so a lot
of these people look like business
people
and it's kind as long as you talk to
talk
you know you're all right so undercover
i've reversed
chemicals and equipment to make meth
undercover i bought methamphetamine
in large amounts i bought heroin
and then
there's an individual
which
a lot of people have heard their name
before they used to be a famous mob
hitman sammy the bull gravano
he was out in phoenix and witness
protection
but still doing
bad activities
so they actually put me undercover he
actually had this group of kids out
there they were
into mma um and they were selling
ecstasy
in steroids and this group would go
around and they would beat up like they
would pick a minorities and jump them
like five on one
kind of like a one percenter motorcycle
gang thing
and they put me in there to buy steroids
from these kids
so i ended up buying steroids from these
kids and it
later led to sammy the bull getting into
additional
legal problems
where is he at right now
i'm not sure where he's at the moment
that's crazy uh when you're doing these
undercover ones that you're talking
about are you staying under cover for a
long period of time or are you basically
going undercover for two hours to go
meet these guys buy some [__] and then
roll out did you ever do
these guys it seems like they're going
undercover for extended periods of time
that's called like a deep cover
operation
those don't happen that much anymore you
know there's a lot of risk involved in
that you know so you know there were
some like
some of the pseudo cases where like i
played a role for like months at a time
but a lot of it was done over the phone
and stuff but most of them was like you
know
you're meeting with the guy you know you
know for this hour or two you know
you're in the undercover role
and then you're moving
on
to the next thing you know and the
biggest thing where people think is
if you know you're
undercover and
a suspect are you the police you're
supposed to tell them yes i am you don't
have to tell them the truth
oh that's not true no that's not true
and when you're interviewing people you
don't have to tell them the truth either
you know you're interviewing a couple of
people and like like when you're like
you and kim went to talk to that girl
you just told her you had all this
information yes or you arrested a couple
people and hey your buddy's in the next
room just spilling his guts on you
saying it's your dope and your gun this
no no no no it's it's his you know and
they think you need to tell the truth
and that too you know you can
in those circumstances you don't have to
naturally tell the truth did you do a
lot of that interrogation type stuff
yes did you get trained to do that did
you did it send you through training or
was it just what you learned over the
years
in the academy you learned the basics of
it and there's different schools like
the read school and everything i never
went to a formal school
most of that
i got was on the job training
you know i got with some you know
agents and some local police that were
good at it and just picked up and
learned
you know hey this seems to work this
doesn't work
you know so i just like i said i had
kind of a knack at getting people to
talk
and also like i said good with
informants
all right so
after you got done with that conspiracy
thing what was the next thing you had
the west side task force and the west
side task force that's when you're
working with the the regular police from
phoenix
and you're all working together to try
and
do good do good yes you know and people
don't realize that
without the local law enforcement we
can't do our job
you know the locals they know the area
they have the local connects and
everything
and most of the dea groups
have um local law enforcement's
officers sworn in as task force agents
in the groups you know because we can't
do the
do the job by ourselves and i kind of
helped me me working at a local law
enforcement agency first too i kind of
had respect and street cred from a lot
of the local officers and i didn't think
i was as big bad
you know federal agent and you're just
this lowly peon local law enforcement
officer
you know i i respected them
and so what are you guys doing you guys
going after
like different levels of drug dealers or
what's what's what makes that west side
task force different than just regular
dea it was um we focused on the west
side
okay in the west the west area suburbs
and is it is it the fact that you're
working with them closely in
interoperability and exchanging
information that gives you a better
chance of catching bad guys
yes and it also bolsters our numbers too
and we actually in this west side task
force we actually worked
in one of the
west side police agencies
off-site locations for the glendale
police department in arizona
so we're actually you know you're with
them
every day day in day out
so same thing you're doing
investigations but you're utilizing the
local cops to help you do the
investigations correct is that right yes
okay
so you're doing that and then i kind of
pulled you back in the story a little
bit but you but then you you started
hearing about the fast company
and what you could do what that's going
to look like but you're 39 years old
you've got some mileage on them yes
and so you're trying to get in shape for
that
um
how did you find out you got picked up
or what was the application process like
well you know he had to fill out this
you know fill out this questionnaire you
know i've been on the job you know this
many years and this is kind of the
background of things i did on the job
and you have to get your
uh
concurrence from your supervisor and and
then the concurrence from the special
agent in charge whatever division
you're in and you submit it and if
you're qualified
your name is picked to go to selection
so they set a date for selection and
every they give you a list of you know
hey these are some of the events you're
going to have to do
kind of give you outline how to train
for them
you know you have to do our standard
deapt test
which is no great shake
you know you have to do the shooting
pistol and long rifle but you get to
score higher
ruck marches
you know with weight on you during a
certain time a distance run
[Music]
you know on all these different thinking
and you know kind of thinking on your
feet and leadership different tasks and
things and
you actually have to we use actually use
this company
that
the
before
a lot of
people in the military go through
different special op selections they
have to take this test online
which is kind of like a psychological
and like an iq test
and you got to answer these questions
and then
they can pretty much figure out if a
person is going to make it or not
through
how you do these things somebody needs
to tell the damn seal teams about that
because we still have an 80 attrition
rate after however many years it's been
60 years or actually no it's been
freaking 70 80 years of doing that
training and putting people through that
training we still can't figure out who's
going to make it well if we can quit you
know and we do to you know so and i
think
we started with um
i think there was close to 40 of us in
our selection and only 11 made it
through today where's the selection take
place quantico the first part yes the
first week it takes part and quantico
all in house
it's kind of like is it a beat down
oh yes
it's kind of like we call it like our
hell week and who's running it um
is it agents from fast and fast how long
has fast been around for
was it created after september 11th yes
after september 11 yes but you said
there was a previous like unit that
would snow cap yes that was prior to
that so they took maybe some old snow
capped people brought them back
see if they could help out something
like that yes how do you know get them
get the unit organized and the training
and logistics and you know weaponry you
know but you're going overseas fighting
the war
so you're using weapons and weapon
systems the average dea agent doesn't
never use in their career you know
you're using you know belt fed crew surf
weapons
you know grenade launchers um
you know uh
handheld mortars right um carl gustav
rockets you know laws you know all kind
of crap
you know so
you know you're doing all this stuff so
you know you they really
you know invest in you and like once if
you make it through training you make it
through selection
and you get picked up
on a fast team you have to least commit
to doing three years
because they're putting all this time
and effort and training into you
um so what made most people quit
how long was it how long was the
selection process the first hell week
was like a week
and you had tier one events they were
their pass fail
and if you fail one event you're gone
and then we had tier two events
where tier one event would be a forced
rock march force rock marshals certain
titles here's the time yeah
right here's the time
um a distance run was like a five mile
run
rpt test
um shooting test
things of that nature uh a basic swim
qual
got it and then the tier two were like
just you know different other events and
if you failed one tier two
you were put on probation
and then if you failed another one you
could get removed we also had peer
revivals throughout too
because we had learned
life lessons you know some people can
just fly through all the physical
activity things and some people had a
lot of military experience
but they can't play well with others
so you're living in confined spaces
you know and you're just living with an
[__] yeah and we didn't have time for
that so you could actually get peered
out too
so
so are people quitting this selection or
are they just not passing the standards
about a little about half of both okay
you know you know and when you go
through there they're telling you what
you're getting into
you know this is what you're getting
into
and
this unit is not for everybody
and just because it may not be for you
it doesn't mean that you're a bad agent
that you can't do your normal job but
this is what you're getting into and
it's a whole it's a total volunteer unit
so you get people that are going through
slacking and you're just getting your
dick knocked into dirt
and you know and if it was just you know
you did you every day you did like a
tier one event
you'd be fine but you're also getting
hazed in between
you know and carrying the logs and and
the inflatable boats and you know doing
crossfit workouts and
you know you're 39 years old 39 years
old you're not getting much sleep but
they're feeding you well okay that was
the average age of the rest of the class
i would say
low
low 30s low 30s
okay so you know did you have trouble
with anything
the water stuff
i've always looked like you might be a
little bit of a sinker
you know and i learned that muscle does
not float that's why i say that man yeah
we we learned that in the seal teams
like you get these big jacked guys that
are not only big and jacked also ripped
and that means they don't have a lot of
body fat and that leanness doesn't help
either oh yeah leanness doesn't help
either yeah you know so i grew up with a
swimming pool and we had a cottage on
the lake in michigan so obvious i always
say i was fairly competent in water
but
just
and i had to learn in the pool
you have to relax
the more you get yourself worked out you
get oxygen deprived and then you're
screwed
so you know for treading water for long
periods of time and you know swimming in
bdus and boots and everything
you have to stay calm
you know we didn't quite do the 50 meter
underwater swim like you got we did a 25
you know in bdus and to me you know it's
like you know they kind of tell you to
go deep and you know and stroke and
glide and you know i'm doing all that
and then
when you get close to the wall it's like
i'm starting to do the panic swim
i'm screwing myself you know
you know so
yeah relaxing glide that's easier said
than done in many exactly you know and
keeping your breathing controlled and
everything you know so you know after i
did enough to pass with the swimming so
afterwards um
when i got selected on the fast team the
fbi had a pool over there so i'd go
there a couple times a week and just go
into water and just swim
and get better at it
so so how long was the whole selection
process you know the first week is like
the hell week and then you do a training
phase next
and that's usually a couple months
and that's usually run
by oda green bray team or with us
it was going to be naval special warfare
with the seals and i was the first group
that was done by the seals and sometimes
the first part goes
and then you go right into your training
phase
and um
[Music]
i mean the first part goes
first the little hell weekend that you
encourage people to quit yes and then
you go right into your training phase
but we got to have a break because
we were going to use maybe special
warfare that weren't going to be ready
for a couple months
so we got to go home and
heal up and lick your wounds a little
bit you know i pretty much had a blister
in every part of my foot i lost every
toenail on both feet and at the time my
girlfriend picked me up from the airport
after the hell week and she's like
what the hell happened to you of course
i was beat the [__]
i had to go to the er room the next day
is that my foot was infected you know
i'm trying to tell them what happened
they're looking at me
i don't this doesn't sound right you
volunteered for this he volunteered for
this
and just because you make it through
everything say the hell week
still the fast cadre
they sit down and you have to be asked
to go on to the second phase of training
so i made it through that and got to go
home and just lick your wounds for a
little bit and go back to work in your
regular group and then we reported
in early spring we started selection i
think february 2009
early spring of that year
to little creek virginia
to do our second phase of training
so we're like okay you know we're told
this is your learning phase this is
supposed to be the gentleman's course
now
roger roger that so
you know the seals had never had outside
people there either
so we show up and some of the cadre and
some of the people from team two and ten
hey um we got a bunch of old bdus for
you guys and what do you guys get in
your badges and this and that they'd
have no clue i'm like well i had my past
for 12 years
and you know we pretty much got a lot of
high speed stuff so
we're staying at the navy inn there in
little creek
and so we report zero dark 30 the first
day
and for formation of pt and
we go straight to the ocean
good times team too in the ocean out of
the ocean you know sugar cookies whole
and i'm like oh really i'm like um i
thought this was supposed to be a
gentleman course
and they were like we were told to treat
you guys like butts i'm like who the
hell told you that damn you know so you
know got he got hammered and
but you know they kind of you know
slacked off you know for a while and you
know he had
different things distance runs and stuff
so we spent time training there and then
we bumped over to fort chaffee arkansas
to do the land warfare part of that and
you know it was it was it was very
very good training to say the least and
it was funny before we went over there
and we found out the seals were going to
do our second phase and other buddy who
was very competent
but he was struggling the water a little
bit i called him and i was like did you
hear her in our second phase he goes
yeah the sale is like
yet
and then you kind of you ended up coming
out the west coast to do some training
too because you yes later on that's
after i got selected on the fast team
okay so when so when did you actually
get selected
october of 2009
okay and just because you make it
through all the training it doesn't mean
you're going to be picked up on the fast
team
because as the openings occur
you can get cherry pick from the list
got it
so you was there anything else uh about
the
the initial training course when you
were at team two you went to fort
chaffee you go do training out there are
you training with a task unit are they
just putting you through training as
your own entity
that one it wasn't like they were as our
own entity oh really so you had you know
people from trade it there and actually
um
a senior chief um
tony gayle was assigned to us
do you know him oh yeah yeah tony he's
he's such a beast so he's like uh
uh
smaller than me he's shorter than me he
looks like uh how do i describe this he
doesn't look like he's like a super
beast but he's faster than me and he
could bench press more than me so he was
like better than me at everything and no
one would ever you know suspect that and
you know he can go through the obstacle
course pretty good he's freaking awesome
he's freaking awesome then we had a
master chief hitchcock too oh yeah
helped out right on right on yeah i know
both those guys with things and so yeah
it was um
it was it was intense and of course we
would do different events
you know but the team guys and
if we did a distance run of course they
put their distance run stud out there oh
yeah or if we did a crossfit workout
they put you know their best crossfitter
out there out there you know
you know so they kind of cherry picked
you know people but you know i don't
blame them you know when you show up
there okay we're doing a distance run
you couldn't wear any watch no gps and
we're just to run yeah and so you guys
get did get hooked up with a little bit
of extra bonus program yeah it wouldn't
tell you know how long we're running for
yeah you know i've always been a bigger
guy and i cut weight for that because i
knew we were doing all the endurance
stuff so i was sitting around 215 220.
but we had some guys on our teams like
in the 160s you know i can run a couple
six minute miles but i can't run six
minute miles for 10 minutes
and we had some of these little rabbits
they could do that and that not me you
know i blow through a crossfit workout
no problem but yeah you know so we've
gone these distance runs and we went you
wouldn't know how long you were going
for when you were done it's like you
know just do your best you know
okay what's the time hack here
well we didn't not telling you you can't
have a watch on so you don't even know
how fast you're going anyways yeah well
that they were treating you like bud
students because in buds you don't have
a watch and it's a total pain in the ass
you never know what you're doing the
only thing you can do is just go as hard
as you can because that's the best you
can do you know when selection what i i
didn't try to look too far in advance
i just took each activity for who it was
you know when you're being beat down and
on our team day the last day of
um help the kind of hell week i was just
like hey joe just take another step
just worry about one more step
and then we'll worry about the rest
later i didn't try
to overwhelm myself
you know and i read some things before
but you know about different selections
and things and that's one of the things
they said don't overwhelm yourself
just
worry about one thing at a time
and you make it through that well you
worry about the next thing then
so you get done so did you do anything
besides chaffey
land warfare with those guys
we went to chaffee
and then back to the creek
and then you would culminate you know
you're doing ftx's um throughout and
then it culminates with a final ftx
where you got to hit a target over there
and you go in you know with sims and
everything
and they didn't have the
the the miles gear like we had in island
there
and you know you'd do a hit and
the group i was in we
had to fast rope on top of this
building at night and it could be tricky
we're using our dea pilots
and they hope they can hold a hover good
because there was always a couple times
when guys um almost were going down the
rope
and the rope's not over the building and
you know i've always been a heavy guy if
i'm full kid or i was carrying my aw i'm
not stopping myself on that road that
was me too i'm not when i'm going i'm
going that road better be in the right
spot because i'm going to be at the
bottom of it in about two seconds and
that's that and it's funny when we were
doing our fast rope training
at little creek and the towers and
everything you know you start with a
tower at first and you do your
rappelling and everything and you know
okay just take your time sit down you
know and the helicopter you know then
grab the rope and then slowly spin
yourself just take your time
so when we go on the helicopters the
first time to free you're like go go go
hurry up go go go
what happened is take your time thing
you're like eff it i guess we're doing
it live you know
uh so you get done with that and you
said that's when you actually got
selected or chosen to go to a fast what
do you call it fast companies best team
fast team so you actually get selected
to go to a fast team and that's in the
fall of 2009. correct october 2009 and
when you get there are you going do you
know you're going on a deployment at a
certain time well we knew what team you
were going to we had
five teams at the time
alpha through echo and each team is made
up of one supervisor
eight agents and one intel analyst so i
knew what team i was going on then once
we got there
they
would tell you okay
we always had a team in afghanistan all
the time
and each deployment
lasted 120 days give or take some days
so you knew when you were going up
so
um
once i got there i was assigned to delta
team which was made up of some senior
agents
and with some of the newer individuals
and um we were set to go to do the
first deployment in afghanistan was
going to be the
spring summer tour
of 2010
and a lot of people don't know in
afghanistan there's a fighting season
over there
you know it gets bad weather there um
it's winter and stuff like that so in
the spring summer that's when all the
fighting's going on and that's when
they're
harvesting the opium poppy
to manufacture
the heroin so that's kind of your
busy time
so
you get settled in and you do start
doing your plea to pre-deployment workup
kind of like you know with the military
and then we had a group come in
you may be familiar with them
um they're made uh made up of ex
navy special warfare guys and actually
some dev group guys called
um
shoot shoot
shoot the david group okay
right off and um they actually we
actually used um
your guys's system
and developmental groups of combat
clearing okay so they actually taught us
in that and then that's when we find out
uh before deployments um you guys are
going to
camp billy macon in nyla california and
doing land warfare
with
a west coast seal team right off right
on you know
you know what when was that do you
remember when that was yes
um
should i find taxis i want to say april
may
ish of 2010 yeah um so yeah i was
definitely still there and sqt you
weren't there when we first got there
yeah you showed up at the end yeah i
show up for the ftx's yeah that's what i
would do and um the sqt was going
through there at the time
hey and um so it was a full house there
how was that training
it was intense you know it was you know
three weeks day and night of you know
getting
you know kicked in the balls you know
and you know
this is what i was told in the seal
pre-deployment workup that's usually the
hardest um pre-deployment block or the
toughest
yeah the land warfare especially at that
time was no joke yeah you know so there
was a lot of buddy carrying you know it
was for extreme distances you know
you know and you know different things
but i i tell you you got to learn how to
do
you know
land warfare drills very effectively you
got to
get to know how to use your equipment
your night vision your lasers
very well you came out of there well
prepared like
you know knowing that something happens
in combat you know but you you know you
ran out there you know you're training
there for worst case scenario yeah yeah
and so it was yeah that was always my
goal was that and
you know the goal is as crazy as a goal
this may seem like the goal was oh okay
um
i want to make sure that these guys if
they get into a gunfight it's they're
going to be it's going to seem easy
compared to what they've been through in
training and i had countless guys come
back to me and say hey this is the
situation we're in here's the gunfight
we got and here's the contact we got and
here's the scenario we were in
and they were able to handle it
exquisitely because the training the
land warfare training that they'd been
through and the urban training that
they'd been through was so hard
that the actual combat seemed easy now
obviously can you simulate someone
actually getting wounded or actually
getting killed no you can't but as far
as especially from a leadership
perspective understanding how to manage
all those elements on the battlefield
and then the young shooters being
thinking shooters and knowing how to
execute knowing how to operate knowing
how to move themselves that's just an
awesome package that that you have you
have this just unified team when they
get done with those with those training
cycles so it was nice because in island
you know they didn't you know they broke
us up and just intermixed us with the
team yeah you know so they put a
couple's you know with this you know
fire team that fire team so they kind of
mixed you in so it was
it was it was very
very good training a lot of the
the train and stuff there and nylon was
good because it's very similar to
afghanistan terrain too i was get we
were trying we had some some other
military entities trying to get control
of that training site for us and i
remember i put together a brief for my
leadership in the chain of command my
most senior leadership in the chain of
command and what i did was i took
pictures of nyland
and pictures of afghanistan of like
seals patrolling an island and seals
patrolling in afghanistan and i put
together like five or six of those
pictures side by side in a in a
slideshow
and i said this is the terrain we're
fighting in and this is the terrain
we're training in we can't do any better
than this right here and we need to
maintain control listen so yeah it's a
it's it's very
it's almost uncanny how similar those
two environments can look
and i didn't realize when we were there
he had two army rangers you know doing
an exchange program to help teach the
land warfare there yep yep um you know
those those rangers that we would bring
out they're just outstanding guys
because we as seals always want to have
an open mind and make sure that we are
understanding the tactics the techniques
the procedures of other units what do
they know better than us what can they
teach us what can we learn from them and
that's one of the ways that we've always
done that is taking
individuals from other units and
bringing them to our units especially to
our instructor cadre so that we can
learn more and try and get better and
those those ranges that work with us
were just outstanding guys
and i say
and i feel you guys do an outstanding
job of your guys's training um you know
like you said you know knowing that hey
there's always you know
there's more than one way to skin a cat
yeah and let's see what other people are
doing you know you you put things in
your toolbox and hey i might use this
again or hey i may never use that again
but you have a lot of tools in that
toolbox yeah indeed
so you end up going on deployment to
afghanistan your first deployment how's
that
it's um
intense
every time we go to afghanistan things
are a little different and at the time
we
were doing a lot of work with the army
odas the green berets there
and at this particular time we were
operating in panjawai area
you know the the panjoy
kandar area is kind of that area is kind
of the birthplace of the taliban
where there's a lot of insurgent
activity but also a lot of heroin
production going on there also
so they broke us up into like two z's
and threesies
and put us with different units
and
a good partner of mine
a friend of mine travis brooks and
myself
we were signed with um
first special forces group over there
oda 1231
and they were stationed in camp simmons
just a little little base outside of
kandar airfield which is like our main
base was at kandar airfield in
afghanistan we were living with the
oda the first group guys
you know and we would bring
like i said earlier our expertise on
investigations and we had our partner
force over there which we were mentoring
and we were living over there
with the green berets
and using our intel information you know
from the dea and also using the military
information
and we would try to
pair that information
find out where the
bigger drug labs were
where they were selling
the chemicals and equipment to
manufacture heroin
and we would not go after the opium
farmers
the poppy farmers because a lot of times
they were made to grow the opium
you know the taliban came in and they
had the biggest stick at the time either
you know you're growing this poppy for
us you're getting killed
you know so we knew they weren't reaping
the benefits so we would try to find you
know the people who were getting the
money from this
and
it's called a narco terrorism nexus
and um so we would hit these bigger
locations and take people off the
battlefield and train the afghans out of
process and
try to conduct these you know
investigations and
we were um
with the
the green brazier at the time they were
doing
movements to contact
which for the non you know military
people and i didn't know at the time
because i wasn't in the military before
you know you basically go in a hot air
and you pick a fight
and you access
assess the enemy how strong they are and
you stay there for a couple days
and then a lot of times conventional
forces are brought in
and we were hitting areas where a lot of
drug activity was going on and
and of course in panjoy at the time
[Music]
they had a lot of implanted ieds
yeah yeah this is 2010. yeah so ied
threat is just full on at this time
especially in that area you know and
that's when they started switching over
to
like the homemade explosive the hme
where the metal detector is not picking
the stuff up you know we had dogs and
stuff
with the bomb guys and gals but
sometimes they couldn't smell it and a
lot of times these ieds are hidden so
well you can't see where they're at
and especially at night under nods
you know in every mission people were
getting you know injured with ieds you
know that was
you know in a straight-up fight most
often than not they couldn't hang with
us
you know so they you know they use their
weapon to ied and you know to
inflict terror around us and um you know
it's like okay um
this can be my last step i have my legs
you know you're trying to do everything
to try to you know mitigate it but you
know you still never
never know so you know we're doing these
movements to contact and
you know we're most often than not
hitting these labs behind enemy lab
lines
and that's their money they're fighting
like hell to keep it
you know so
i think that first year
i think i did we did about 11 missions
or so
and it was only two times i didn't have
to fire my gun
and i carried um a bell-fed weapon
at the time i show up to fast um of
course the listeners can't see i'm a
decent-sized guy what are you walking
around out at that time weight wise um 2
30 ish okay so they're giving you a belt
fed one yes you're like you're a big guy
you carry that i've said i'm old and
it's still heavy you know you carry a
mark 48 or mark 46.
actually a mark 43. oh damn okay you
know old school m60 echo 4. that's
freaking crazy you know that was made
you know for you guys you know
you know um we had mark 48s
but
i'm a left-handed rifle shooter i'm i
was all jacked up i was very left eye
dominant
and i shot a pistol right-handed in that
mark 48 you would eat all the brass and
link the mark 43 was a little better i
put like a broomstick handle on the
front and i moved it way back and i
could stand
stand up and i tuck my right elbow real
far in
and so i wouldn't catch as much lincoln
brass you know the cyclic rate of fire
on that mark 43 is not quite as fast as
the 48 but as you know it's it's a
pretty reliable
it's a it's a reliable weapon
you know so i carry that damn thing
every mission
you know and it's nice to have because
it does a lot of damage
but has uh automatic gunner
the enemy knows that so you're a target
too 100
you know and tracers work both ways yes
they do
and luckily at night i got a hold of
some of the ir tracers
which you can only see under nods and
usually the enemy did not you know for
the most part and that there
they did not
have night vision capabilities so
yeah it was um you had to you fire and
you move your position a little bit and
you fire move your position a little bit
and you know it's not like tv you know
they had a box of 100 rounds on that
gun and it doesn't last for five minutes
you know if you're hamming that trigger
down
it goes pretty quick so you gotta learn
to conserve your ammo and spread load
ammo with other people too were you
going out with so you're going out with
an oda team at this time yes and you
also would have afghan partners with you
yes so these are pretty big elements
that you were going out in yes and the
oda had their um partner force too
oh so wait so you guys had your own
partner force yes
wow like a dea an afghan dea yes it's
the national interdiction unit okay
um the afghans they were more their
investigators and then the green berets
or whatever group they had their own
group two right which the um green braze
like to use the afghan commandos that
was kind of like their special ops
unit
you know but to be quite honest with you
even like we were working with the best
and brightest
it was like herding cats oh for sure
yeah you know it's like okay you know
what's you know you couldn't do these
advanced like
um
wedge and echelon movement always like
single file those get in line and we
hope you can stay in line get mine and
please stay in line and stay behind the
bomb people and this and that
you know don't walk on like the path
doesn't look like people walk the most
don't go over the foot bridges because
that's where you're going to place the
ieds and within 10 minutes on the ground
they're everywhere i'm like oh jesus
they're going to get me blown up
[Music]
how big would these elements be so you
got the oda team the commandos your guys
and then the the afghan dea of whatever
you called them yes what are you talking
like you got like
50 people yeah
it depends how big the operation is you
know a greenbreak oda team we got like
12 individuals
and their partner force probably would
be around 30
you know and fast because we were like
twosies and threesies have two to four
fast agents and we would bring our
partner for us
at this particular time like we could
cherry pick people
that were the better
fighters
and sometimes two to four we would take
out and to be honest like i said we
worked the best and brightest
not a high percentage of them were good
fighters
and a lot of times they weren't in great
shape
so we're kind of limited what you can do
how long of an infill an ex-fill you can
do and
how complicated a plan
right you could do so you know it kind
of hamstringed us a little bit you know
but we went out there
and got the job done
you know when we were really hitting
them hard
you know they call it second and third
order effects you could see they were
having trouble getting some more of the
better munitions and stuff
when we were like just
you know putting a smack down on them
and um
halfway through that first oh near the
end of the first tour we had
uh first group was leaving and then a
group from third group came in oda
and they came in and
we did a couple missions with them and
i know you're probably familiar with
this and some of the listeners is you
know that the afghans
they use these icon radios to talk with
each other you know we intercept these
things you know a lot of times they're
just talking [__] on these damn things
you know we're killing them you know
they're married they're dying no we
found your id and we're blowing it up
you know
that's what you just heard and
you know so we're
getting
at the end of our tour
and
we're going to hit this spot
um
called hazy madod
in afghanistan
and there was a little combat outpost
out there
which i think 101st airborne was out
there and
they had a taliban hospital in the area
of course they were growing a lot of
marijuana and poppy seed out there and
but they also had several dishkas in the
area the enemy dead
and that's the old like russian
anti-aircraft weaponry 51 and they would
harass the coalition forces
their air
so
you know we had several tasks in this
mission you know to find drug you know
to eradicate some of the drug activity
going on and also find these discus
so the rangers went in there before us
and they got in a pretty good dust up
and tick tick stands for troops in
contact and they lost a couple rangers
so we were going in a couple days after
and
you're doing your
pre-mission briefing and you know we're
going to get inserted with you know
three ch 47 hello four ch-47 helicopters
and there's a high probability we're
going to lose a helicopter on infill
with the dish goes and you know you're
sitting there the night before oh [__] i
hope it's not me you know you're like in
a coffin up there you know even
most time when we flew with the um the
green rays they used to like to use the
night stalkers and 160th
and we would always infill an xville
with a spectre gunship overhead
you know but still that's not any
guarantees
and so you said night before i hope it's
not me you know it was not a helicopter
to get shot down so
we plan this up
and we infill we usually like to go in
at night
to use the
our advantage with our technology with
our night vision and layers lasers
because i stated earlier the enemy
usually doesn't have that so we like to
go in at night um
get a foothold the best we can and then
when it's light
search
and then you know exfil the next day or
depending on how long the mission is
going to last you know
a day or two or whatnot
so
we fly in and we take a little incoming
fire but
all four birds make it so
we begin to sweep through
and get a foothold and then
for individuals who are listening that
were you know been over there
usually
they'll try to hit or probe you the
enemy over there
after first after morning prayer and
then usually they do their first hit
and try to
feel you out so
we get in a couple little skirmishes um
see him plant some ieds and
you know we're okay we're moving through
and we didn't find
where we were at we didn't find the
discos we're finding some marijuana
fields and this and that
throughout the day they're talking
they're like um we need to find a good
place to set up our pcm machine guns
meaning the enemy
and you know we blew up an ied and like
i said earlier you know oh we are
killing them you know we're you know the
americans are screaming and
so you know they're you know setting up
their pk i was like okay you're just
you're bullshitting whatever screw you
so
this is in august
and it's hot as hell
and
we didn't have any close air supports
at the time was they got
called over to some other units that
were having some contact
so we had a predator overhead but the
predators
wings iced over and had to land you know
this is you know 115 degrees you know
110 degrees but like you know you
they're flying up higher and i don't
know the specifics and stuff so
you know we're in
sporadic skirmishes so
we were under fire so they're like um
we're not going to send air to pick you
up
because the lz is pretty going to be
pretty hot
so you're going to have to make it we're
going to have to try to make it to this
combat outpost over there
which
was probably a couple clicks away at the
time
so
we move out and we stop this little like
village area and we get set up to make
our final push
and it was just
the villagers there
just had it just we had a funny sense
like a spider something something's not
right
you know you know when we get in there
where are your id's how we do not know
where they are
okay so okay you're going to go out in
front of us and
and
you're going to take us through
you know and you get to a spot i will
not go any further you must kill me oh i
thought you don't know where the ieds
were
you know so we found a couple ids and
blew them up and so where
the termination is made we're going to
make it to the combat outpost so at this
time we're probably about
clicking a half away or so
so we're moving through this is daylight
and we're in a single file and
one of our guys
sees some movements in this little hut
above us and he's like
tells one of the green brace hey um i
think i saw some movement so he glasses
it with his um scope and doesn't see
anything
so we're moving out and
i'm
next to like a pony wall like a probably
a couple foot pony wall to my right of
me
and i'll tell you one thing those old
mud buildings like when you're over
there those mud
you can explain to people but unless
you're over there you can't believe
people still live like this but those
stuff those things do a hell of a job of
stopping bullets and stuff
so we're going through and then sure is
[__]
they were looking for places up to peak
camps we got caught in a near ambush
so i got bullets going over my head
coming to the side of me
and people are calling off we got four
people hit right off the bat when ambush
opened
one being the oda team sergeant and he's
like i got a femoral bleed
and we're like oh [__] so
um
i'm rocking my 43
and i usually carry about 400 rounds of
ammo on me and we had spread loaded some
more and so
you know i'm trying to pick up like
puffs of smoke where i think enemy fire
is coming from
but i'm also trying to conserve some of
my ammo too because if we start getting
overrun i want to have some
but i always carried a pistol with me
too and at least one frag grenade
because if i could help i wasn't you
know i'm going to fight to then i'm not
i don't want to be taken alive
and so
i'm rocking through ammo and
in the near ambush you know people are
throwing hand grenades it was that close
you know firing law rockets and i asked
one of
our afghan counterparts who spoke
english and the
oda counterparts they carried the
full length um
240 bravos
so it's the same round that the mark 43
would fire so i'm like go get me some
ammo
so he runs out
and brings you back a little link of
ammo about 24 hours like what am i going
to do with this
so i just link it on one of my belts and
i said okay
and
um so we're fighting and we finally get
some close air support we get a f-16
from the uae but they won't fire
and you know we got people hit and we
got medevac coming in and i tell you
those medevac pilots have balls of steel
when they come and they started coming
in rpgs were shooting up all around them
they landed those birds and got our most
severely wounded people out of there
and um
you know back to you know higher care
you know so we finally get some close
air support to suppress it a little bit
the um 101st here's all this activity
going out so they bring some of their
gun trucks
but they can't get too close to us so
we're like okay we gotta make you know
we're getting a little break so like
okay we gotta make it this combat
outpost
so we did um
our vote our version of the mogadisha
mile there
where you know you're running and
shooting
and you're not caring about the ieds at
this time you have to cross open field i
guess you know you're up you see me i'm
down
you know i guess if i step on some [__]
i guess i'm gonna blow up
and you know they get their gun trucks
out there and they start shooting
getting some pressure fire
and
we ended up getting to the combat
outposts and of course we look all look
like soup sandwiches
you know when i'm done here i was like
you guys are out there you go yeah good
i learned in the combat you know we got
stationed you know set there and you
know got some rest and yeah you know
we're gonna go to the cha-ha and get
some food and that's when i learned most
of the bases we were staying at did
unlimited food
and that's why i learned the combat
outposts there's limited rations yeah
you know you only get
you know what's there little serving you
know so um
grace of god everybody end up surviving
you know we had some
some injuries but we ended up surviving
so that
concluded my turn and i tell you what i
had about you know i thought it was
going to end that day because when you
come close to running ammo you're like
oh [__]
you know what i'm going to do
you know so it was
it was quite an experience so we kind of
went out with went out in a bang that
first her
yeah
so so yeah you
definitely seem to end that deployment
with a bang when you when you got done
with that deployment as you looked back
at it what were some of the takeaways
that you got
from your experiences there
like anything i've done in life okay
every mission i would take it
for each mission it's like okay these
are the things i did right in the
mission these are things i want to do
the same again and these are the things
i did wrong and i never want to do again
so each thing i you know i looked at
myself critically i've always been
probably my own worst critic
these you know i don't want to do that
ever again you know and this is what i
want to do
and
you can probably relate and some of our
listeners probably
the more you're in that environment you
never get 100 used to it but you get
calmer during it i remember my very
first
operation it's all dark 30
or with the green rays that year and
lucky we didn't get any ticks or
anything
is i remember landing in the middle of
the night
in the middle of nowhere and i guess i
said
i guess this shit's for real now
and i'm just trying to make sure i don't
lose my element at night you know night
vision is you know it's not the easiest
to see you know you know and we had some
pretty decent night vision it's like
please please lord let me keep up with
the people in my group and not get lost
out here by myself
so you know and i told i was talking to
my fellow some fellow agents back
in arizona when i got back and i was
telling them stories you know this is
what we're doing you know you're like oh
you're bullshitting there's no way you
did that [__] i was like oh yeah we did
you know it's common you know everything
kind of
fell in the place where i don't know if
it ever will happen again
you're at war with a country
that's has a drug nexus right you know
so it's i did things as a da agent i
never thought in a million years i'd be
doing
and
you know people would ask me were you
scared or nervous i said yeah hell yeah
i was
you know i said but you still had a job
to do
you know
there's nothing you know scary or
feeling you're going to land and you're
you're giving you know you know five
minutes two minutes and you hear the
door gunners open up you you know you're
going into a hot lz you know you
had to unask this bird you know start
putting some fire down
but i explained it to it it's like at
the amusement park you're riding the
biggest baddest roller coaster you're
scared and nervous
and then when you get done it's like
okay when we going back again
you know i guess i gotta get that warped
sense you know i've always been kind of
an adrenaline junkie but
you know it's like ah
are you nuts i i don't know if i'm nuts
but
you know i tend to
i've always even in football
tend to excel when the pressure was on
you know some people fold
under pressure some people can handle it
well
luckily for me i always had a knack of
being able
to still function
pretty effectively under stress
when you got home from that deployment
you said you went back to arizona do you
know back to um quantico okay so you got
back to quantico yes so is that where
you're actually living now as in
quantico since you're with the fast team
well i'm retired now but when i was on
the fascine yes i was living in the
quantico area i was living actually in
fredericksburg virginia okay so you get
back from that deployment no one can
believe what you did you can barely
believe what you did i'm just lucky to
make it out there with my life you know
and have two legs still you know uh and
then what's next
you get it you get to decompress um you
know you get to spend time with your
family you know you've been gone a while
um they send the the psychologists in
and they kind of debrief you and see if
you have any issues or problems and you
just get to take it easy for a while and
to spend time with your family and just
relax and
recuperate
and how long is that decompression time
you know usually a month or so nice you
know and
so then you know we were scheduled to do
our next tour in afghanistan it was
going to be the late
early winter tour of 2011.
and the meantime
we started operating in the western
hemisphere also
and we had a team
out there
echo team
which their primary thing was to western
hemisphere and they were giving us
language training in spanish and
everything
and um
they were operating in honduras
a real [__] too
um roatan's real nice so the you know
the scuba diving destination and stuff
but the rest of the country is a
disaster
a lot of a lot a lot of violence there
so
echo teams going there and they're doing
which is called these air tracks of
interest
and we were working in conjunction with
joyce joint task force bravo over there
out of sodocano
and what you're looking for is these
small like planes these cessnas and
different things coming from source
countries
like cocaine peru and stuff like that
loaded with cocaine you know multiple
hundred kilos of coke at a time
and
the you know they would fly in and land
in these uh remote landing strips
and their so-called remote lane was like
a road or just like a clearing
and they would come in there at night
with no
no night vision and no
um runway lights and just have like
things lit up and land and you know try
to
safely land the plane but the drug
dealers didn't really as long as the
the
the cocaine was okay they didn't care if
the plane got destroyed
so we were we were sent to um they
needed volunteers so me and another guy
from my team volunteered to go and help
them out
so
we go
and we're in soto kano we're doing
training with
our partner force there um
getting up to speed and our tactics how
to take down a plane land and take down
a plane
and all that jazz and working with joint
task force bravo
and
right before we got there
we were doing some training so
another team went there
they had one of these air tracks come in
and they launched on it
and actually got a pretty good fire
fight and actually we're shooting rpgs
at
the you know the military aircraft the
47s that were bringing them in
and
the the joint task was bravo guys like
whoa whoa tight time out you know we're
just supposed to provide you guys a
minor transportation role we don't
really want to be in combat here
so
when we got there they made a pretty
good seizure and killed some you know
decent amount of enemy
and um
so we get there so they're like in like
well
okay we have to have so many hours of
training and
you know we have to practice this and
that and so we're practicing and doing
all that
you know waiting to go and then dea we
bring some of our our airwing
assets there but we just have smaller
vehicles i mean smaller aircraft like
kind of like a super blackhawk you can't
fit a bunch of people in there and we
were you know you're doing assault you
want like a ch-47 or something
so um
they're making every excuse in the world
not to fly us and was this for a
specific target that you were going
after um or was it just in general they
were making excuses not to fly if a hit
happened to come up in general okay
because they knew
that there's going to be gun play
and one of our honduran partner forces
got
shot during that first operation they
had to medevac them out and they're like
if we sent you guys down there and if
somebody gets hurt we are not flying
into a hot lz to get you
so there's a lot of a lot of things so
we had 2d aircraft there so we had a
couple
good air tracks that came up
so the first one
we launched just with our dea birds and
the amount of fuel they can carry is not
that great so you can't be up that long
and it takes a while for us to get on
these these um
these bogey birds
and get tracking them um so we launched
and we had um in each one of these
helicopter two dea pilots
we had two fast team guys and
two
honduran partner forces and these birds
and each one of these birds we had a
full-size 240 bravo on there
and stuff but
with that limited people
you're not going to land and fight a
force
so at best we hope to see where they
land and hey if we got harassed and
maybe you know you could defend yourself
and put some fire down at least disable
the aircraft
so we'd launch
twice and we get on both tracks
but before they landed
we had to we're running low and running
low on fuel
so we had to get back
so we're there and we're staying out at
porter castillo
near port castillo area there's a base
out there that's we're launching from
so they had it was a pretty big media
event so they all knew where the
excuse me they all knew we were there
so one of the local drug dealers he
knows we're coming so he leaves the
country
so one of his
people that works for him one of his
lieutenants is there
so he concocts this
hair brain scheme he's gonna get de out
of there dea is gonna we're gonna get
them out of there so my boss can come
back
so
we're staying in this hotel so wait so
one of the local drug dealers says to
himself i'm going to get the d.a to
leave yeah so that the big boss man
could come back the big boss man oh
heffy can come back
so we're staying in this hotel and
there's
off the water there and
there's another hotel there the
christopher columbus where a lot of the
military guys are staying and they had
this little airstrip there so a lot of
those fast guys would get in the morning
and do pt and we'd run in the morning
so this guy's scheme was they knew a
kind of our
schedule
that they were gonna
when we got run in the morning they're
gonna go and
drive up and shoot a couple of us down
so
they're going to kill a couple of d
agents and d is just going to leave and
wait you got wind of this or this is
just what their plan is you found out
after the fact we end up getting wind of
it because
one of the partner force guys we were
working from
recognized a guy in town
and he said this guy in town got
recruited to help kill a couple of us
so
he reports back he reports this to his
buddy and they come to us
and the two people they're going to kill
in the morning
is the big guy which is me
and then another guy on our team dave
claussen the guy with the funny shorts
because he has these like colorful long
goofy shorts he would wear to run
and they're just going to pull up
alongside of us and his machine gun us
down
so
we get wind of this and then they get us
the hell out of there back to soto kano
and
send us back to the states
what about the other dea agents um they
were there like another week and they'd
be left it was just there was it was at
the end of when we were going to leave
anyways and plus it's high risk low
reward high risk low reward jtf bravo is
not flying us so it's
it was just it was just a mess we later
went back there and had full support and
ended up doing some good with some other
teams
how did you feel when you were trying to
get out of there walking from the
freaking hotel to the car to the
airplane to get you out of there i tell
you what you know we're staying in this
hotel
um
casa alemany house of german
by the water there and you know we got i
got a first floor room
and it's a decent-sized room so i'm like
against them one night there so i'm like
barricaded my door
i got my mark 43 set up
ready to go my you know my car being
ready to go i'm like okay lord get me
through this night i said if they're
going to get me they're going to have to
they're going to have to work to get me
you know
so it was did were you able to sleep or
just stay awake all night finger on the
trigger i didn't i just leave my you
know i had you know i had the you know
the
belt you know down the feed tray cover
shut you know
uh
you know what the weapon cocked back
with the safety on you already ready to
go you know so they're gonna
you know i'm gonna respond with a burst
of gun fire they try to get through here
you know
so it was like you know
you know i survive afghanistan and then
i'm gonna get um i'm gonna get
hit in honduras you know
so i'm coming coming home like oh god
joe what are you what are you getting
yourself into and you're volunteering
for all this and at night in honduras at
night
there would be all this
you know fully automatic ak-47 gunfire
and the couple who ran the hotel is that
just like celebratory fire or
there's was there fights going on
i think a little bit of both got it and
the people who were the proprietors of
the hotels oh they're just killing
chickens ain't killing no damn chickens
in the middle of the night with aks with
aks yeah be nothing left of the chicken
you know
so um
we roll back into the states and then
we're doing our pre-deployment training
getting
ready to go to my next her in
afghanistan
so again we're
in the fighting season
[Music]
you know time frame parameter
and um
you know working with these specialized
special ops units
if you hadn't worked with them before um
and you can probably know this
there's a lot of dick measuring going on
check it's like who are you what can you
do if they never work with you
you know you know we weren't a special
ops unit for say you know we're the best
the dea have but we could shoot move and
communicate pretty good you know we
could hold our own
so a lot of times
it took two or three missions of going
out with people hey these guys are
pretty good you know they're decent
um so a lot of people thought that
we'd go with these units and they would
clear it and then we would come in after
the fact that wasn't the case we were up
there from the front leading elements
um so to get to my points we had our
fast team before us that was there
in afghanistan and at the time a lot of
the u.s special ops units were doing
these fields stability programs where
they were going out and living with the
people out you know in the villages and
getting them to
kind of
see our way of thinking and views and
values and you know we could talk for
hours just about that
but we won't get into that
here today
um
so
no u.s special ops um units were
available to direct action missions so
the australian commandos stepped up hey
we'll do it
and they were operating they could only
operate in the helman province in
afghanistan and that's a pretty hot
insurgent area surgeon area of activity
and they have a lot of drug production
goes on there and that's where uh we
have a big base there camp leatherneck
where the marine corps is our marine
corps is
so
they were working our fast team came in
and they saw we were good to go
so when we got there we didn't have to
go through all that rigmarole we just
hit the ground running
and in fact the second op we did there
that tour
we had hit the biggest heroin lab to
date at that point in time in
afghanistan
and it was just huge and
they weren't used to us being in
hellmann
so we weren't running into a lot of
in-placed ieds
because they weren't used to us being
there
but
they were still putting up a hell of a
fight you know if you're trying to take
their money and oh hell no um so
we hit that huge lab we had how big is
that lab
like like is it
that they're producing um at a time
multiple hundred
hundred kilos of heroin at a time
and in fact when we came in they had a
lot of it drying out
we didn't know and you know the rotor
wash of those seats blew a lot of it
away
but there was just a ton of chemicals
and equipment left you know then we you
know we can't
take all the stuff with us so we
we just take representative samples take
photographs and destroy the rest of the
stuff in place so we're you know in the
process of destroying the stuff and
we're running into sporadic you know
gunfire encounters we got one of our um
our partner force guys got shot in the
leg
and we have to bring them to a medevac
and some a couple of australians got
shot
and
we're processing
this slab and
i tell you the the australian commandos
they're
they're very very effective unit very
good
you know i kind of
put them on par to like maybe our army
rangers and they roll in pretty heavy
when we roll in too
they will
deploy snipers in there first to set up
and if we're rolling heavy they'll bring
a whole mortar company and everything
too
so we um
and that's who you started working with
and they were being guided by the
aussies yeah we were being guided by the
australian australian commandos okay
that's who our partner force was and
it's funny because like we'd be talking
like this and you can kind of understand
the aussies and they have different
slang words and stuff
but under um stress and under
firefighting you can understand what
taylor is saying you're like can you 10
9 that last please
okay and my very best english accent
this is what we want you to do
so you know and you know we had quite a
few prisoners at the time during this op
and stuff and
you know you're getting ready in the
middle of night you're loading them on
this helicopter and they've never seen
helicopters up close
you know so they're just looking around
they think it's like an alien spaceship
come on
come with us we're not going to execute
you come on
you know so
we're
we're rip rolling through this tur we're
just making some hell
of a seizures
so we're getting close we got a like
three weeks left to go it's getting
close to halloween
and um
this bizarre peak bazaar
and the northern helmand province pops
up hot
you know in these bazaars out there like
outdoor flea markets with like rolling
garage doors and things and they sell
everything from
you know sundries and shampoos chickens
but also to include chemicals and
equipment to manufacture heroin
ied bomb making material and small arms
so this bazaar pops up hot and our team
fast team that was there before us bravo
team had hit this bazaar with the
aussies
and they seized a lot of items and they
got in a pretty big gun fight
and in fact the supervisor of the fast
team brett hamilton
who was in my selection he was um
a marine corps officer old tough crusty
guy
and we were the two oldest guys in our
selection he was a little older than me
um they're fighting their way back to
the helicopters
and he ends up getting the forrest gump
wound
a bee jump up and stung him he got shot
in the buttocks
hard or hard dude man he stayed the rest
of the turn you know they packed his
wound he was still going on ops and
stuff so
we knew we were going to run into some
resistance
but when we could hit it with the
aussies
there wasn't an air wing platform
available with night vision
capabilities that could fly us
so we're like we really don't want to go
during the day we want to use our
technical advantages
but
we
didn't have that option
and
we were
[Music]
our confidence was
i think a little higher than it should
have been
you know they say you live by the sword
you die by the sword
so like we're gonna go so
we're going to use this air wing
that's training the afghan pilots for
when we left they could take over and do
stuff
and they were using old russian mi-17
troop transport helicopters
now it's a pretty robust helicopter it's
not it's not as big as our ch-47 but
they move pretty fast and
um they get the door and the door
gunners they got on one side a pcam
machine gun
on the other side a gao mini gun
and
there's u.s
contract pilots in there with with
afghanis and there's one british guy
british british aviator two
so the night before they tell us
okay
um
one of the helicopters you guys are
using is going to be all afghan crew and
piloted
who are like oh
um
we don't really want to be on that
helicopter
nor any of our aussies because if they
decide that they're going to
get their jihad on that day and crash
into a mountain
don't want to be on that
and they're not quite as skilled as our
pilots
so we're like okay
um
we'll go but our afghan power
counter force is going to infill and
exfil on that bird
so we get a plan we're going to hit the
bazaar early morning hours
of october 31st 2011 just after first
light
you know we want to get there with no
people in the bazaar
you know so we have to deal monkey
around and deal with all that crap just
get there we're going to hit this bazaar
then we're going to hit another location
after it
so the plan was we arrive in
three
mi seven no four mr17s
some fast fast team members and
australians are going to be in one
the afghan pounder force is going to be
in another and then the
australians are going to be on the other
two birds
and
the um
australians are going to land and kind
of set up an outer perimeter to try to
keep the enemy from maneuvering in on us
but the only bad thing is it was a
little bit of a mountainous area so the
enemy had the high ground on us
and our afghan
partner forces are going to land in the
helicopter
they're going to search this little
village area right outside the bazaar
we're going to link up
and then we're going to
search the bazaar in two groups i was in
charge of one of the elements made up of
fast team members with some our afghan
partner force
and then one of our other guys was
leading the other group so we land
start moving through hook up with the
afghans and shortly after infill
we receive start receiving sporadic
incoming fire
not very effective
so we're moving through and we're
finding poppy seed and stuff to
manufacture heroin and
i'm standing
outside of one of the stalls in the
bazaar behind this old capita car
i hear a shot
fired and i hear it hit the beat up car
behind me and then i feel the back of my
neck burn
i'm like oh [__]
so i dive into the stall the bazaar i
put my hand on my back in my neck to see
if any blood i don't see any blood on my
glove
i have
whenever afghan translators look at it
and he says oh it looks okay so
but the bullet got so close i could feel
the heat of the bullet burn the back of
my neck
so i kind of had my guard up after that
and i'm like that's a close call joe
so i kind of was using all my techniques
and tactics i had learned throughout the
years
on the police department on the swat
team as a da agent as
the dhd fast training and prior missions
so shortly after that
over the little shitty
loudspeaker system they have over there
the insurgents do a call to arms
today's your day to die we must
kill the infidels we must drive them out
of our land
so
the incoming gunfire really increases
so we really hear the aussies get into
it with them and you're still in the
bazaar at this point we're still in the
bazaar and the aussies are on external
security yes and we have the marine air
wing providing close air support
and we hear the the marine airwing get
into it the aussies getting into it
so we're finishing up what we have to do
we're taking the samples taking
photographs and starting to destroy all
the stuff
so
we do that and we say okay we're like 10
likes 10 minutes out and we'll be ready
to move
so we start calling our birds to come
get us
so they're inbound and we have to make
our way to our ex-fill locations we're
only about a couple couple hundred
meters away not far but we get bogged
down in the gunfire
so we can't make our x-fil positions in
time
so we have to wave the helicopters off
so they go a distance away but keep the
rotors spinning
so
you know at this time you know we're
like
moving in between mud huts and you know
you're leap frogging and you're like
oh you know i know we have to get the
hell out of here because the longer we
stay the more the enemy has time to
amass
you know and it's not going to be good
but you know in combat
you can't
show fear to other people on your team
or squad even though you're feeling like
i don't know if we're going to get the
file out of here
you know so you're moving and we finally
get set up in our xfield positions
afghans and their little spa and
us and the aussies so the four
helicopters come in and we're receiving
pretty heavy incoming fire to to include
belt fed machine gun fire
don't remember don't recall any rpgs
so the four helicopters come in and we
got the afghan crew and piloted
helicopter that one we're never going to
get on
in a million years
and three land
guess which one doesn't land
the afghan crew and piloted helicopter
and afterwards they said because
of the brown out conditions with the
helicopters helicopters picking up all
the dust and rotor wash and all the
incoming fire
they didn't feel comfortable landing
so instead of waiting for their bird to
come
guess what the afghans do pile on to the
next helicopter
that's ours
so they get there first um we're in this
open field we run out there we're like
get the hell off they're not moving i
don't blame them i wouldn't want to go
back into that hell
so instead of being shot in this open
damn field
we're like okay just go
so the three helicopters lift off
and then it's us fast team members and
several aussies
so we how many guys are left on the
ground um like 10 15 of you yeah at max
we had from fast we had
we had
jared
justin
to matt's
um
brent
paul
[Music]
myself and a couple aussies so like
under 10.
so
of course
all the fires focused on us at this
point
so we take cover in a little ditch
and then our helicopter short time lands
about 100 meters away and that's the one
we're never going to get on afghan crew
and pilot helicopter
so they land
and um i remember saying to myself of
course your heart's racing
you're like i gotta get the hell out of
here um
i remember saying to myself this is
gonna be a shitty run
you know there's bullets just popping up
everywhere
so but i knew we couldn't stay
so
one of the last memories i kind of have
from that day
is i get up to run
i remember firing a couple shots on the
run towards the direction i felt the
insurgents were firing at us from
i guess i got the helicopter about
mid-pack and that's when i paused
and
was providing fire for the rest of my
teammates to get on or near the
helicopter
and then once that happened
my
team leader jared johnson said let's
roll i guess
and that's when i turned left to run
onto the helicopter and i got hit in the
head
at first he thought i fell
and he's trying to rouse me and i'm not
moving i'm face first into the ground
and then he rolls me over and he sees
the like ballistic glasses i was wearing
were shattered and he sees a hole in my
head
so they roll me over
and
they're thinking i'm dead which is a
very you know
very possible situation here you get
took around to the head
and so they grabbed me scooped me up
threw me in helicopter that's when brent
and you know he's putting cover fire
down
uh matt stewart's trying to get the
afghan door gunners to fire they're not
even firing
and helicopters getting shot up
you know we're getting shot and he's
like shoot shoot shoot so they fire a
couple rounds you know burst into the
ground so he's like no shoot shoot so he
takes you know he grabs the gun and
starts shooting a little bit
so they throw me on the helicopter
and um
you know they think i'm dead you know
the helicopter is very loud in there of
course and everything so you can't hear
breathing
so one of my teammates justin vanderbilt
who
actually before dea he was a medic
in new orleans and he was there during
katrina
so he was kind of like one of our more
highly trained kind of our version of
like 18 delta medical guy even though we
all go through pretty
intense
t triple c combat care and
actually live tissue training and stuff
he's like he's alive
he's breathing
so they start getting my stuff cut out
and um
they
apply combat gauze
to my head wounds
which is gauze with clotting agent in
there
so they're getting that under control
and then a lot of times with facial
wounds or different that head wounds you
want to try to establish a better airway
and you know and you can do that by a
couple different ways you can do a crike
where you cut you know then the person's
throat and you insert and implement or
help them breathe more or you can use a
nasopharyngeal airway
and they decide they're going to stick a
nasopharyngeal airway up my nose
and in training we have to insert these
in on each other
and um just so everyone knows this is
like a
it's basically like a u-shaped tube that
you cram in someone's nose that will
open up the airway between your nostrils
and like your lungs not all the way down
to your lungs but like through your head
you know they're probably what do you
think they are joe like maybe
five inches long total something like
that and one end looks like there's a
funnel on there and
the other end you know and in training
we can put lidocaine
in our nose before we do it but it still
sucks or no
no offense attended
um when you're training with the seals
they allow us to spit on them and
stickies over those nose and these are
not fun
and when they're cramming this up my
nose i come too
i don't remember any of this it's
probably a good thing
um
i'm talking making sense
i recognize people's voices
i'm not complaining about my head even
though i have a hole on each set
i decide i say get it out of my eyes
the pressure from the high velocity
round which we think
was the arm repressing round from
belfast pkm machine gun
traveling through my head ruptured both
my eye globes and detached both retinas
so they pour saline solutions on my eyes
of course that doesn't do jack crab
and then i'm telling them i gotta move
my leg
so they think i'm shot in the leg too
with all the gunfire that was coming at
us
and this particular mission i did not
have my belt that machine gun i had my
car being with a suppressor on it
and i had been shooting quite a bit
so when i got knocked unconscious
i fell on the
barrel of my rifle and suppressing it
burned inside of my left leg real bad
and actually the cry pants i was wearing
were burned you know they were burned
and
um
they you know they burned my leg pretty
good so they're you know they're working
on me and you know they're getting me
back to the base as quick as possible
and i know my teammates said
the thing that scared them even the
bleeding stopped my head just kept
swelling up and swelling up
they knew there was nothing they could
do there
but luckily for me
the helicopter was there when i got shot
so
you know
i usually take the time now to talk
about some of the things that
i think led to my survivability
is that you know even though i was
severely wounded
by my team
providing that fast medical attention
they had stalled my decompensation
giving time for me to get the higher
care
and
i know it's not in vogue at times or
this and that
but for all instances i should be dead
talking to the medical professionals
over 80 percent of the people who get my
injury do not survive
and the day i became a police officer
my
mother gave me a saint michael's
medallion it's a patron saint to protect
police officers and always carried one
on me i had one in my kit
i always did the psalm 91 prayer before
i went on missions and carried a copy on
me that's the prayer of soldiers going
into battle for the lord to protect you
and i had one of my grandfather's dog
takes in world war ii on me
and
it was not my time to go
the lord had more for me to do i think
some of that is me doing my motivational
speaking now
helping others deal with situations and
instances and it just was not my time to
go
and then with all our high-speed medical
training that we had
once my teammates found that i was alive
nobody panicked
unfortunately over there we had to use
our medical training more than we had
liked
so that and also
you know i talk
about mindset
you know you have to have this mindset
that if you're in a fight
for your life or you're with a suspect
or an enemy
you're fighting for your life or getting
in a shootout
or it could be you could be at home you
could have an accident or driving a car
if you're in a fight you have to survive
you have to fight
you have to kick
claw scratch god whatever you have to do
you have to think to yourself i am not
going to lose this fight i am not
going to lose i'm going to survive
i'm going to make it through that you
have to have that mental attitude
you know i kind of call it the
warriors mindset or the winning
mentality
that i'm going to survive and make it
through this
you know there's no way i'm not going to
make it through even though
at first i was not unconscious
my body
my mind
give up
you're gonna you're gonna make it
through this joe you know i didn't see
any bright light or anything i may have
saw some little fire below or something
it wasn't it wasn't time
so um
also
talking to the doctors
i was in really great physical shape
when i got shot
and
the better shape you're in a lot of
times
the more traumatic injury you can
survive
and
a lot of times the better your recovery
is so you know so when i talk to groups
you know especially military law
enforcement groups you know i tell
people you have to be an olympic athlete
but please please please
be in the best shape you can because it
may save your life you never know like i
said it could be a car accident you're
in or you could fall of a ladder at the
house
you know just please stay in the best
shape
that you can
so
we fly back to the base taren count
which we're staying at with the aussies
so we land at an airfield there and the
ambulance comes out to meet us and
they don't bring
a stretcher to the bird they think they
have me on a stretcher even though we
have them
they didn't have me on one
so i hear this commotion going on
so guess what the guy shot in the head
does
he gets off the walk off the helicopter
my team is like no joe we got you who
will carry you
so they carry me to the ambulance bring
me to the medical facility there
they do what they can for me there do
you remember trying to get up and walk
no
i don't i don't remember talking to my
teammates on the helicopter none of that
all i remember is firing a couple shots
on the run
because i you know talking to the
doctors because i guess you know when i
got hit it was just lights out and it's
kind of your
brain's mechanism protect you
and i'm
probably glad i don't remember any of
that stuff
so they brought me the medical facility
there they knocked me unconscious did
what they can for me there
and then they make arrangements to fly
me in a medevac
helicopter to kandahar airfield
which they had a neurosurgeon and eye
surgeon standing by
so i'm flown over there
with one of my teammates matt stewart
we
arrived there so they of course they do
an assessment on me there
and it was fortunate for me that day it
was halloween so not a lot of groups
were doing or units were doing missions
so they didn't have many casualties
in the hospital there
so they first take a look at me
and
i guess i'm starting to be
kept alive with basic life-saving
procedures at this time
and they don't think there's anything
they can do to save me
so they're just gonna have me
pass peacefully
and then have me sent home back home on
an angel flight
deceased
but the doctor the neurosurgeon he's
pretty aggressive guy and then the the
nurse it in took me there
and he's looking at me he's talking to
my teammates you know my teammate
that i was talking after in the
helicopter i got up to walk off i was
trying to get whatever's in my eyes out
and he sees what shape i'm in he's
convinced that
if he gets in and performs surgery
that they can get the
bleeding in my head stop and some of the
pressure relieved at least get me home
to the state so my family can see me
didn't know what condition i was going
to be in even though i you know i was
talking in the helicopter
and he had to
decide
whether i could survive even what he was
going to do to me during surgery
and he felt strongly
that
i had the will that i wasn't going to
die
and he told me after the fact
with brain injuries and head injuries
he said there was a smell that somebody
gave off
that he could tell if they weren't going
to make it or not
and he said i did not have that smell
and um
the head nurse there you know they're
bickering back and forth whether you
know he's fighting the command whether
they should use their resources to save
me and i guess there's a line
in the hospital there once you cross
over that line
surgery has to take the patient
you can't push them back
so
they had nurse at the time which i'm
still friends with
i'm not going to mention their names i
don't want to get in any trouble
push me over that line
so surgery had to take me
so they be they began to operate on me
the neurosurgeons spend approximately
four and a half hours operating on me
they actually removed the whole
frontal skull piece off my head
my front all my frontal forehead is now
titanium
they got the bleeding stopped
they got they put a valve in there to
regulate my pressure
and then the eye surgeon came in
and he's like she's like talking to the
main doctor he's like is he really
survivable
am i going to spend all this work on
somebody where he's just going to be
sent home in a box
and that was a possibility but he says i
think you know he's gonna make it
so she spent approximately eight hours
piecing my eyes back together with a
microscope
and this work she did
has given me the opportunity in the
future
to be able to potentially see more
my left eye has some light perception
and i can see some movement in my left
eye and i can see some shapes so there's
a bigger color contrast between light
and dark
so she pieces my eyes back together so
the next day one of my best friends on
my unit he was in another part of the
country trying to get some other ops
together he makes it there
and he flies back and routes the states
with me of course they have me on this
big i guess medical
plane
you know pretty much
each patient has their own nurse and
everything
and we're in route back to the states
and of course they're letting my family
know what happened and
everything and at the time
i was engaged
and i told my fiance at the time i said
don't um if i can't get a hold of you
you can't get a hold of me i'm out of an
op when i get back in we'll
um skype or and i'll text you or call
you
i should only worry if um two people
come knocking on the door
so she was a nurse she worked night
shift and she
afghanistan was like eight and a half
hours different
and um
she hears a knock on the door that
morning she got back from work and she
goes to the door and she sees two
gentlemen through the window she doesn't
recommend and they put their badges out
and she's like oh [__]
so she opens the door
and she starts bawling they're like he's
not dead
he's in surgery we don't know but he's
alive at this point
so they get all my family notified and
everything and then
we had to fly over to longstool germany
and they had a pretty good medical thing
there
with my buddy travis and was the
pressure my head was rising they kept me
there for three nights and then
they flew me
to
um
andrews air force base i was going to
say dover but you don't want to make it
to dover because that means you're dead
um so they flew me to andrews and then
had all my family at the hospital and
all the people from dea and everything
that the higher-ups and you know some of
the other people on other teams waiting
to receive me
so they take me
via ambulance over to walter reed
national naval medical hospital in
bethesda maryland
so
they when i arrived they let my family
see me
they plan on doing some other surgeries
there
but of course i'm a mess
i have no frontal skull piece
my head's all caved in i guess you know
i'm swollen i got a tube coming out of
almost every part of my body
and they let my family see me
and at the time
[Music]
my fiance was
a
intensive care nurse so she's seen a lot
of trauma a lot of bad things
but i guess when she saw me of course
when it's your loved ones it's different
she put her hand on her mouth screamed
ran out of the room and passed out
her dad had to help her off the floor
you know it's when it's somebody you
love and care about it's different
so they brought me in there they did
some surgeries on me they reattached my
retinas
they cleaned up my head area more
in preparation
for putting my plate on
my metal plate that i have now and later
but they don't want to put it on too
quick because the chance of rejection is
greater and everything so
they want to wait so
they um
do that
and then they
put me in an induced coma
with that that profile
you want to maybe call it the michael
jackson drug
the one michael jackson used to sleep
gotta rest michael jackson you know god
rest his soul
it works very good for putting people in
a coma but you can reverse them real
quick but not necessarily it's not not
necessarily prescribed for sleep
um so they had me on that and they had
me um they had me intubated and
everything so they had me induced coma
for about a week
and then when they
were getting ready to bring me out of
the coma
they didn't know how i was going to be
even though i was talking and making
sense on the helicopter and all that
with the additional trauma of the
surgeries they wouldn't know if i could
speak at all would i remember anything
would i have my same personality
but they certain
shortly after they learned i was the
same smart ass joe i was before
you know i was a little confused at
first
they asked me you know
where do you live
i'm like oh detroit michigan what do you
do i'm a police officer
what's your dog's name i said max that
was my very first dog i had when i was a
kid
but i soon shortly after i got my
bearings i knew who i was at the
particular time i knew i was working for
and everything
so then started my road to recovery
you know so now i'm blind
um
i'm not in the best you know the best
condition physically at this particular
time because of the injuries
you know so
they begin to
start my recovery process
and i was on a feeding tube for a while
so they had to pull that out and they
trick you
they say okay we're gonna pull us out on
three
one two
like oh you didn't wait for three i was
like
i'm like we say that because we want to
catch you by surprise you don't want you
to say three then pull and then you
tighten and it makes it worse
so i had to learn how to eat solid food
i failed a couple swallow studies at
first and
you know of course i'm losing weight by
the minute because i'm not being active
and the people at the hospital oh he's
got a lot of muscle he's in good shape
you know he's and mike's wife's at the
time where ex-fiance
you didn't see them before
so we started meeting making them feed
me you know like ensure in between meals
and stuff to try to put some more weight
on and
reduce things like okay today your task
is okay joe have you put your shorts on
and your t-shirt and your socks
you know how long is it going to take
you i said you know obviously five or
ten minutes or whatever
so the one time i'm sitting there with
the physical therapist and my
ex
and um
i'm feeling these shorts
and i'm like these don't feel like my
size
i'm like what size are these
and of course
my ex doesn't say anything like a church
mouse she's like she knows she's telling
me what size they are
i'm gonna throw a hissy fit
so the
therapist says let me see i'll tell you
she goes they're medium
i took those shorts i threw them across
the room i said i'm a big fella i wear
extra large if i were to put those extra
large shorts on there they fell straight
to the floor
because when i got shot i was probably
two thirties really lean
and
they would weigh me on the bed every day
i was down i got down to like 160
something
so those shorts what was the time frame
for that
like a month
two months i spent two months there
not
not not long
so we got over that and then i was i was
confused and then
of course my eye doctor he was his name
was dr chung there and a very serious
man so one day we're sitting in my room
my father's there with me and my
teammate travis and dr chung
walks in and travis is like dr chung i
want to tell you
joe thinks he's african-american
i was all jacked up so i'm talking and
acting like i'm an inner city
african-american guy and
lingo and everything and dr chung like
are you
serious
and trouble says yes and then my dad's
like well he is from detroit
so
dr trump thought it was pretty serious
but i only acted that way for a couple
months you know a couple days you know
and then i got my bearings back
so yeah it you know it
it progressed there and they did
everything they can for me there and
then
they let me
start doing like a little bit of workout
stuff there and they brought me to like
the little pt gym area and they're like
okay we're gonna have you do like some
little dumbbell stuff and like okay tell
me which way where are the 120s yeah
with the weight you know tell me it's
good i said oh these are too heavy no
these are too heavy these are too heavy
okay these are good
and then i found out after the fact
actually joe those were the pink
dumbbells you were using oh no
you're like two pounds
oh i don't care i'm getting in work you
know
yeah yeah you know so um it did that and
they start you know teaching you how to
um
operate blind and i don't know for some
goofy reason
i thought i didn't have any skin on my
head where my brain was i thought it was
just like mesh
so they're like joe
you need to take a shower we need to get
you a shower
i'm like i can't get my brain wet
and max is like joe you have skin there
i'm like oh i do
so you kind of lose all your dignity you
got to go in the shower with this you
know this nurse or whatever they're all
gowned up in all this rubber gear and
you just you know stand there with your
birthday suit on butt naked oh my guess
i'm taking a shower you know
and so how long was this you know
recovery process how long did you stay
was that was this still taking place at
bethesda
yes i was there for two months two
months
when so you lost
freaking whatever you went from 230 to
160 something yes and now you start
rebuilding yes well and and when you
start rebuilding does that really start
to take place when you get out of
bethesda
yes because they transferred me down to
the
maguire va down in richmond virginia
you know after that so it was kind of
nice but we're getting close to
christmas time now ish
and
um
so on the weekends they let me go home
as long as i came back sunday night
and i got to go home for the holidays
and then we became started doing a lot
learning there a lot more how to
operate in a blind world like use the
blind cane
use some of the voice over stuff like on
the computer and things like
that and i began to let me start working
out more there
you know sir during this time
i'm like i don't know what's going to
happen to me or not happen to me and
i'm like our administrator at the time
her name was michelle linhard she was
like in charge of us
and she asked my buddy travis what does
joe want he's like joe wants to keep
working
she goes we'll make it happen so even i
didn't meet the physical requirements to
be a dea agent anymore
they kept me on as a dea agent
after this because they figured out the
money you make a lot more retiring as a
regular agent rather than taking a
medical disability so they kind of
hooked me up and
during
my stay in
walter reed
bethesda
i'm hearing my teammates
and my parents talk about
theirs they bring all these wounded
service members back home from overseas
tore up bad
a lot of these are younger kids
when this happened to me i was like 41
years old
i lived a pretty damn good life and a
lot of these kids
maybe not married maybe newly married
uh maybe just had some
[Music]
you know
a child and
you know their life is stressfully
changed forever
so when i would have my pity party and
why me
woe is me
you know i would say joe
it always could be worse somebody always
has it worse than you
you know you can't
control
what you don't have anymore
all you can do is work and work with
what you have now
so
in life when bad things happen
we can make a couple choices
we can let life pass us by or
we can get out there and do as much as
we can do
and i made a commitment
to myself that i'm going to try to do as
much blind
as what i could see i didn't know how
that was going to look
but i made that commitment
and when there's a will there's a way
if you want to figure out how to do
stuff and make stuff happen it may not
be the same way you used to do it
it may take you a lot longer but if you
really want to do something bad enough
you can do it so i made that commitment
right there right then
and i tell people when i talk
it's not been easy every day is a
struggle for me i still wake up every
day blind
you know i've had a very
severe traumatic brain injury i've had
pretty bad ptsd
because of it
and i've done stuff to manage and
mitigate that
and
you know when i talk you know with the
amount of suicide from service members
and this and that you know a lot of us
want to play we're tough and it doesn't
affect us and this and that
but you can't get help unless you admit
you have it
and ask for the help because there are
things and things out there and i got
the stellic ganglion block shot which
helps with ptsd
you have a stellar gland in your neck
when you have ptsd that gland gets all
screwed up
and they go on and dead in the gland and
this kind of like reboots your brain in
your computer and it helps you
tremendously
you know so there's things
things out there
so there's things that i've went on and
done
since i've been blind
i've tandem skydive jumped
and
a buddy of mine his wife out in monterey
california runs a skydiving place
and before i wanted to tandem jump but
i've always kind of been over the weight
limit
and he says for a tandem he's like what
you know what are you going to wage i
said i'm about 2 40 right now and i knew
i couldn't be able to he says come up
and we'll make it happen
so he's when we weighed in his wife
wanted to please this tell me wait 2 30.
so my tandem guy that jumped with me
takes look at me says we're going to
fall real quick you're like how far do
you want to how do you want to jump joe
it's as high as we can go
so um
i guess we jumped at 16 000 feet wow and
i guess that's the highest you can go
without
we should go without ox you know
you know any higher net you want to be
on oxygen and
any higher than that you need to get faa
approval
so we were the first ones to go out of
the bird and i don't know if it's worse
being able to see or not
but you can't
look you know you know you know we
jumped out of a king air you know they
opened that door and the wind's just
rushing you know where the first and
they tell you what to do you know and
we're gonna rock back on you know one
two three then go and then
you know put your arms back and then how
to land properly and stuff but it was
it was definitely a kick in the pants
um
but i do it again probably yes
i'm nuts
and even in the hospital when we're
talking about my frontal brain lobe
injury the doctors told my parents well
he can never be trusted with a credit
card anymore he might just be at work
and take all his clothes off
my mom's like well he didn't make good
decisions to begin with so he's not
going to lose much there
it affected me to an extent but did not
affect me to the extent where
it could have
thankfully
so i also do all kind of i hunt and
shoot blind with special optics
so how does that work um
on top of your rifle
where a scope would would sit
you have like it's like a high-speed
video camera
that has
built-in wi-fi
and it projects to a tablet or a
smartphone
and basically
it'll show on tablet or smartphone
like a site picture
of a scope
and
you got you know assistant gunner a
gunner and they tell me left right up or
down and as long as
i my breathing's controlled and i don't
jerk the trigger i can hit a pie plate
at 300 meters every time since i've been
blind i've shot
five deer
two bucks and three does
i got two alligators in louisiana
with a
we had glock pistol with a laser sight
and i remember before watching that show
swamp people and i can see i said
they're nuts
i said you would never catch me in a
million years doing that
so opportunity came up hey joe you want
to go gator hunting oh yeah sure i guess
that goes back to my poor
decision-making
and i tell you there was some pucker
factor going on there buddy
so i'm with another guy from fast and we
were with the guy we're with
his brother is a d.a agent and he this
guy works um in the oil
business out in
the louisiana new orleans area and he
does the gator hunting
and so
we go to a couple of our lines and it
if the the listeners and whoever said
they've ever seen how they catch them
you have a big like trouble hook with
chicken on it
and they set them up and the gator bites
the chicken and gets caught in this hook
and then you have to go
and pull the gator up and then you got
to shoot them
now in the show like swamp people they
yank on the line to try to get the gator
to go nuts for theatrics for tv
now how you want to do it you want to
pull them up slow so they don't fight
and a gator can only stay underwater for
so long and yada yada so we pull up to
the first couple lines and they're not
touched so we pull up to the third line
and he's like oh [__] we got a big one
you go he's on the bank he's got the
chicken in his mouth he's about a
10-footer
so we roll up in this little john boat
and
we get to the line and the guy's
starting to pull him in so
um i'm on my knees i got this glock with
the laser sight on it 40 caliber glock
you know and i could just press the pad
for laser sight you know when we're
ready and he can kind of guide me in for
the shot
so
we're he's pulling the gator and the
gator gets under the boat he's like oh
[__]
so he's like okay we're not going to
force this
he's got to eventually come up
so i'm thinking he got the gator snout
not too far from me i'm on my knees
and i'm like joe
what the hell are you doing out here
i'm like you're blind
and if this gator snaps
to bite you you can't even see to jump
back and then these locals are going to
be out
you know you're going to see after the
fact
that certain right ain't no blind guy
and no business out there anyway even
the hell that guy in the city i'm blind
out there hunting alligator to get my
arm bit off so believe me there was some
pucker factor
so
the gator starts yanking i like the fact
that not only you're a little worried
you might lose your arm from a gator but
you also don't want to look stupid
exactly you know it's always a key thing
you gotta look
there's a blind guy one arm you know
so
um
the gator starts fighting a little bit
and
the guy is like [__]
he bent the hook and got off
so he's like okay keep your eye on my
buddy's there with his pistol and he's
got he takes the glock he's he's got a
surface
he only stayed on for so long so he goes
look for the bubbles he goes i see
bubbles he
he goes he's coming up so he shoots him
pow
gets him ahead hits him again pow
and the buddy i'm with
he i shoot him too he goes yeah
so he shoots him so we go over to the
gator and then we push him to the shore
to try to get this big sob on the boat
so
as we're trying to get him on the boat i
hear another shot
the gator's already got three bullets in
his head he opens his eyes again
so the guy hits him in the head again
and he's done so we got this big
big gator on the boat so it takes up all
the room so we have to drop him off to
try to check other lines and we went to
our next line he had like a
nine footer on there and he was putting
up more of a fight and i got to shoot
that one twice so
that was kind of um
kind of interesting
havoc actually um
i was in sun valley idaho last year
during hyperbaric oxygen chamber
treatments
because that increases stem cell
activity
trying to get a little more sight back
and i got the downhill snow ski three
times
i did that when i was younger and
it's kind of kind of counter-intuitive
with skiing you want to lean forward
in blind
you don't want to lean forward when
you're walking because you want to crack
your head on things and i've actually
got stitches a couple times in my
eyebrows since i lost my sight because i
was in a hurry
um so that was fun that was on my bucket
list um i tried slalom water skiing at
our cottage up north this last year i
used to ski a lot when i was young
i just i popped up
but i couldn't get my
other foot in the rear boot i couldn't
my balance was off
with blind so i tried a couple times and
at least i tried
um so i did that
i ran 5k races blind and
i've actually last july
i
as you know i'm a little guy
i became the first blind ifbb men's pro
bodybuilder in history
got my pro card so i did that and um
you know the sky's sky is the limit you
know there's different things you know
you can do and you can't cry over
spilled milk and
you can just control what you can
control a lot of people ask me
you know what are some of the hardest
things getting used to being blind joe
i think one of the biggest things you
lose your independence
i just can't get in the car and go
somewhere myself
or if i want to work out i just can't go
by myself and
so you have to rely on other people and
you know i'm typical like the
you know the law enforcement guy or the
military the real type a i want to do
everything by myself you know you can't
you know if you're falling behind i'm
just going to take over you know
you know you want to do it right do it
yourself i have to learn how to slow
down and trust other people
and which was probably good for me i had
to learn to ask for help
i wasn't good at that before
but lucky i have a very good
base of friends and teammates and family
and dea has really stepped up since i've
been hurt
myself or my family has never been
without anything
and at first being in crowds really
freaked me out
because being in law enforcement for as
long as i have
you're always taught to be aware
your surroundings
i i know you're not supposed to um
you know i'm trying to think of the
think of the uh
oh god um
it'll come to me but
i was getting uh on this subject i was
getting uh debriefed by like a
psychologist situation
and
we i filled out some form they're like
um one of the things was like uh you
know do you feel comfortable in crowds
and um i said do you feel comfortable in
crowds and i was like oh well no
and so you know the psychiatrist it's
always a female she looks at she's you
know you
she says
you say you don't feel very comfortable
in crowds and this was like i mean i i
was back from iraq but you know whatever
been a little bit of time and she says
you know you say you don't feel very
comfortable in crowds and i said well no
not really and she goes well why is that
and i go well you know there's
terrorists in america right
yes and she looked like she like
whatever
she started taking copious notes you
know about my mental health or whatever
which i was just like hey it's a reality
you know it's a reality you know you
know because you always want to be aware
of your surroundings okay where are my
entrances where are my exit exits who
looks suspicious
who doesn't
you know you're not trying to like
stereotype people but it's all what
doesn't look right
and at first
being blind
things
of people were sounded closer than what
they were or farther than what they were
i was just real uneasy
but over time i learned to deal with
that so i'm not as jittery in stuff as i
once was i just learned to you know
trust the people around me
and so you know that's one of the things
people ask me do i have a service dog i
don't
i put in for one
but then i got my left eye i had a
chance to get an artificial cornea in my
left eye and i thought i could get back
more vision than i did
so i didn't want to take a dog from
somebody who needed it more and the
artificial cornea helped me see a little
better but not as much
as
we had hoped for
so i still might get a service dog in
the future they're pretty incredible
what they can do they're awesome yeah
very incredible and um
you know people ask me do i get
headaches and stuff a lot no i never had
a headache thank god
because people ask that question and
you know they ask me you know what is
you know
what can you see what can you can't see
like i said earlier i can see shapes i
can see light
i can see some movement on an eye chart
my left eye is 2400 to 2500 depending on
the day anything over 2200 is legally
blind
my right eye is nothing that's the side
the bullet went into
if the eye doctor shines a light i said
i can think i can see a light
but there's future with my left eye i
have artificial cornea
so
there is help the thing that's limiting
my sight is my optic nerve and retina
still very damaged
but they are working on stem cell for
that to regenerate that
and they're
still fairly confident in two to five
years
i could get more sight back
which um
which would be nice and if i do that
would be great but if not you know i'm
still gonna keep soldiering on and do
what you know and do what the hell
you know i can do and they said you know
you don't want to be the first for
anything you want to let them work the
kinks out of this
this stuff first you know you know
before we had all this mess with china
you heard him doing the stem cells and
everything over there and i asked my
doctor so i go to the best eye doctors
that i can now so like you don't want to
go over there joe
when the technology is good
and it works we'll have it here too
so you know just on standby to stand by
for that
you know so
you know we'll keep going with that i do
my motivational speaking which gives me
purpose now
you know i always been you know took
jobs and different things were to serve
people and serve the community i can't
do my job the way i have
in the past
but for me to get up there and talk to
people and tell my story
one is therapeutic for me too
to talk about it
and two
if somebody's having a bad day a bad
year
bad whatever
that to see
there's always somebody that has it
worse
it always could be worse
so you know you got to count the
blessings you have and be thankful
for the things
that
you still have you can't cry about what
you don't have anymore
all you can just do is move on so
you know i'm going to continue doing the
motivational speaking which is good you
know and there's been groups i've talked
to
where i've got after action reports
where people in the audience
um
have
were going to commit suicide and they
heard me talk and they said my life's
really not that bad
you know i i can do it you know so i
tell people you know if i can do it you
can do it you know i've always had a
strong will i've always been very
stubborn
that kind of helped me survive but the
stubbornness isn't always so good in
relationships
you know because i could be
a pain in the butt just ask my
girlfriend
you know and i do really preach
the ptsd part two
because we're losing way too many men
and women for that
so if you do have it and i always knew i
had it but i didn't get better
until i admitted i had it because while
i was still working i was afraid i was
going to lose my security clearance and
this and that
and
in all actuality i would not have
but you know there's things and
treatments and things you can do for
that like the stella ganglion block shot
is um one a great thing for that you
know finding a good fit with a therapist
you know that
you know can work with you so all those
things are important so to me i tell
people
it's macho to say you have it it's not
macho to have it
and say you don't have it you know so
don't be you know a tough guy or a tough
gal there's help out there but please
you know seek that help
yeah
yeah i know it's for me um
you know one of my guys ryan job was was
also shot in the head and uh he also
ended up losing his vision
and unfortunately
um
after that you know after one of the
surgeries one of the many surgeries that
he went through there was some there
were some medical complications
and and he and he passed away
um but
it's
it's for me you know meeting you seeing
you talking to you you know you had this
you have the same kind of attitude that
he had you know he he he had been blind
and he was doing all kinds of things he
was climbing mount rainier he was he had
shot a bull elk uh you know he was doing
the kind of stuff that you're doing so
it's it's awesome for me to see
someone in your situation that has the
same exact attitude that ryan jobe had
just a just a warrior badass that just
was still driving on regardless oh one
of the things i forgot to another animal
that i shot
this past year i went to west virginia
and i shot a black bear
so it was a female bear and i named it
penelope after the fact i got that
stuffed
so that's my little
penelope
what are the workouts
you just do your normal workouts that
you used to do for bodybuilding in the
first place wow
you know i've been doing it for so long
my very first bodybuilding show was in
1993 i did the central states of
michigan after college i was still
looking into something competitive i've
always been a big guy
um and i'm pretty knowledgeable about
nutrition and the workouts and stuff but
i'm also smart enough to know there's
always somebody who knows more than you
so me being blind i can't see how i look
i can kind of feel when i'm getting
leaner and this and that so i do have a
coach
so my coach i check in
at least right now in the off-season
every week
send them pictures or videos how i'm
looking
answering questions you know how's my
appetite
how am i feeling this way in that way
you know getting blood work all the time
to make sure everything is functional
optimally of course i spent a [__] ton
of money on supplements
and the coach kind of guy sees my okay
you know
we'll um you know you need to do maybe
some more fat burning cardio you know
we'll arrange your diet this way
um and also he sends me workouts too to
follow
you know depending on the time of year
you know depending on the workout and
the rep range and the amount of cardio
i'm doing
so it's important too you have to have a
good coach you can trust too that's good
but a lot of these coaches blow smoke up
their clients butts oh you look great
you're going to be mr olympia and this
and that and they can't even win a local
show you know
it's like no no i'd rather have somebody
be honest with me you know hey joe
you know he looks like you're ready for
this competition or you're not and
and please tell me i'll make the
corrections i need to make or maybe
we're going to have to wait on you know
and do a a later competition so you know
we'll see what the future holds
you know i um
if i get some more sight back
i would like to do you know some
tactical training with people
maybe some firearms training
uh i get more sight back i could be a
a coach for people getting ready for
competitions but i couldn't justify now
if i can't see how they look i can't
really do an effective job
you know so keep moving forward with
those things and
if any other opportunities pop up you
know
you know i'll be willing to
to
do those things and you know i'm 52
years old now you can't let these young
guys beat you you got to keep yourself
in shape yes sir
you know i was working you know work
overseas you know with these special ops
guys and like how old are you
41 say okay grandpa
said i got a grandpa for you you know
well hey uh
that's awesome probably a probably a
good place to wrap up so if
if people want to um
you know contact you for your speaking i
know you're you're at
joe
p
dot us that's right right for your for
your website yes i got a website it's
got all my things uh speaking on there
how to get a hold of me and i i've
spoken to all different kind of groups
teams different kind i've spoke to you
know corporations i spoke to people at
quickens loans so whoever wants to hear
me run my mouth i'll talk to
awesome echo you got any questions uh
yeah rewind a little bit back to
afghanistan the um heroin poppies who's
growing that and why
um
the
the taliban makes the farmers grow it
and the taliban is growing that because
that's their money source income
okay so who do they sell that to
a lot of that heroin goes to europe
we get some of it over here in the
united states but the great majority of
it goes to the european consumers okay
got it so just like um you know in
colombia and stuff like that afghanistan
is yet just another hub for another hub
yes and you know it's um you know a real
big country that consumes a lot of
heroin is actually russia too they have
a pretty bad heroin problem there but
you know it's big money and that's you
know what funds their insurgency and the
problem is
now that we're gone out of afghanistan
and how we it's
crazy there again
they're just growing uncontrolled and
like i said when we were hitting them
hard
we didn't eradicate it but you can see
it was having an effect
but now it's just you know bonsai it's
open now it's crazy
that must be uh as you look at
like drugs you're you you spend so much
time in the dea
when you hear people talk about
legalizing drugs
what is your what's your thoughts on
that
and this is just my thoughts only
um
i've talked to numerous numerous drug
addicts
and
the common drug that they start with
is marijuana
and in my opinion without a doubt
it's a gateway drug
and the marijuana that's out there now
it's not the same marijuana that even
was five or seven years ago it's so
strong
you know and it could lead the other
things and you know we could have a
whole debate on that and every state
that it's legalized
um
the auto accidents has really increased
you know it's still illegal federally
you know and and for some medical
conditions you know i can see that it
could be useful for
but in my opinion
a lot of people who use it
say under the advice of medical it's
just to get high
you know and that's this that's just my
opinion
well joe you got any closing thoughts
just um everybody out there just
listening you know like i said there's a
will there's a way if you want to get
something done you can get it done and
just you know have that have that
mindset
and just keep going and if things get
bad or down tomorrow is a new day make
it through that day wake up the next day
and give that next day hell
awesome man um thanks for joining us uh
appreciate you coming on here peace
appreciate you sharing these lessons
that you've learned and and most
important thank you for thank you for
your incredible service and your
incredible sacrifice for our nation and
thanks for what you're doing today
going around talking to people
being here just continuing to inspire
people
to overcome whatever whatever adversity
that they're facing uh it's incredible
example that you set for all of us so
thank you for being here and thanks for
everything you do you're quite welcome
with my honor and privilege
and with that
joe piersante has left the building
echo yes sir what'd you think of that oh
i'll say so i'm used to
and you mentioned this before too we're
very used at this point i'm very used to
uh you know military
guys coming up
their mindset their experience and stuff
like that it was interesting even though
it wasn't a huge deviation i don't think
but it was like enough of a deviation to
seem like a big change to go law
enforcement you know yeah and it
particularly particularly
okay i didn't grow up around drugs at
all like i don't think i've ever even
you haven't been to 500 meth house no
chef cook what mess
labs
yeah what do you call it cook
cook labs k labs or
clan
clandestine clandestine lab
unit or something like that yeah yeah
uh no the answer is no i have not um
i've never seen meth before i've never
seen i've seen coke before i've never
seen heroin before
i've seen weed before
wheat is the only one
i haven't see i've seen a crack head
with an empty crack pipe i don't think
i've ever seen real crack before check
well well definitely you could probably
tell i i was exploring the the police
side of things
and especially you know the the
investigation side of things and the
setup because that's let's face it
that's all stuff that i'm not super
familiar with
and it's very interesting because it's
all about human nature you know
informants and dealers and police it's
well that's why they make all those
movies about that kind of stuff because
there's drama there right there's humans
interacting you know in really stressful
life-changing environments yeah and so
yeah that definitely was interesting and
that's a you know he had a really i mean
he's had a very interesting life to say
the least yeah i mean you could probably
write a book about that one big
bust or the other big bust or the one
big you know you could write a book
about any of those things yeah and it
would be very interesting and
fascinating and you'd learn a lot so
he's done that over and over and over
again and then went to afghanistan and
then had a had a had a hit on his head
in honduras right
i started thinking about you know uh
being in like being in iraq when you're
out on patrol you think someone might
try and kill you you think that someone
will try and kill you
but you think they'll try to kill like
you or someone near you it's not you
generally at least i never felt that way
i never felt like
you know the bullets that say i always
make this joke hey you know bullets say
they don't you don't have a bullet with
your name on it you have a bullet that
says to whom it may concern yeah he had
a bull he had blitz plural with his name
on him
yeah i don't really like that feeling no
i mean you want to talk about you think
i'm paranoid right now which i am
i'm paranoid about stuff right now if
that was going on
yeah i would be enough levels 12 alert
mode no one would be getting near me
it'd be pretty crazy to see i think yeah
there's something
very specifically sinister about a plan
to kill you to kill you specifically
right right
yeah i don't think no i
yeah no one's ever specifically said
we're going to kill jocko
other than dean lister made that one uh
cb yes yeah you need to kill draco cd
but that was just a cd that was just
music he wasn't actually trying to kill
me
so it was somewhat of a conspiracy
though i don't know i will give him that
the um the law enforcement part of it
too which so a lot of times when you
start to talk about iraq afghanistan
and i understand but it does seem like
okay that's a crate that's a different
time in a far away place but now he's
over here talking about san bernardino
like all this stuff and you're like man
all this stuff right now is going on
right now like probably pretty close to
here oh real close to here so and
currently going on right now at this
moment yes like at this moment there's
an informant that's sitting buying some
drugs from somebody there's a bust about
to happen right right now something that
i have literally no exposure to so to me
that is like oh man that's kind of crazy
i didn't want to ask him about lifting
yeah but we would have been here for a
long time that could have been a long
long time i thought you would at least
want to compare bicep workouts with him
you know my man is getting his lift on
oh for sure for sure which actually and
i was going to ask him too but he said
he's age 52 right now and if you can
look like that
at 52 i mean i don't know if he's
getting ready
for a show or something like that but if
you can look like that at 52 that's like
it not only is it eye opening but it's
like promising you you know what let's
just go ahead and restate that if you
can look like that at 22 or 32 or 42.
it's true yeah i'd be less surprised but
less price it does kind of set this a
little bit better of a calibrated
standard you know kind of gives like uh
those of us who want to maintain muscle
mass we'll say yeah
kind of gives you some hope on that one
you know and you know he's not weak
either
oh for sure so it's not like yeah and he
didn't go in too much but but i i you
know read some stuff about him and some
bios and stuff but he won all kinds of
like you know awards for football and uh
he's just a great athlete and just jack
and steel so for sure for those of us
that want to maintain muscle mass have
you ever met someone that didn't i guess
occasionally you get maybe a wrestler
like a fighter or someone that's
literally going down a weight class
below their what they can cut you know
sometimes people say oh i'm resting at
i'm gonna go down to
and i'm already shredded so i'm going to
lose muscle mass right occasionally that
might happen i think when people
get into some if they get into some
endurance sports maybe like triathlon or
something they might want to lose some
muscle mass maybe uh yeah and i'm talk
wait what are you asking like is that
have you ever known somebody that said
i'm really looking to find out how i can
lose some muscle mass no no no no
no negative not just for for performance
sake yes that's essentially it but
that's a rare case um
just life in general they say after age
whatever 30 or something like that like
things like degenerate pretty quick or
whatever that's weird and then muscle
mass is one of those things where if you
just lifted like you're gonna lose
muscle mass as you get older straight up
you're just gonna lose it uh
my daughter was telling me my daughter's
in college and she's studying but she
i was up with her and she was telling me
that
she she's out there jack and steel and
working out she's got her little friend
group and which is cool because their
little friend group they're all they're
all into working out yeah it's good
she's training that jiu jitsu
but
she was telling me because she's
studying
some kind of kinesiology some kind of
physiology i keep forgetting what they
call it now when i was younger so she's
studying nutrition science and
what we used to call
exercise physiology was a minor people
would get right they don't call it that
anymore i forget what they call it but
that's essentially kinesiology maybe
that's what she i think that but that's
different than exercise physiology
she's studying stuff she's studying
stuff about working out kind of right
stronger
but she says she was saying hey when you
if you don't lift
you immediately start like
losing muscle
just degenerating yeah and it's not it's
not like a i mean it doesn't matter like
the process at the end of the day you're
losing you're losing your muscle and a
lot most of its functionality
move it or lose it yeah and then
resistance training which is lifting is
the best one um is the thing that
induces muscle like growth and or
maintenance depending how big your
muscles are so yeah it makes sense so
basically go lift please work out you
know
i mean resistance rate that's another
thing my daughter was she's saying oh
your bones yes your bones if you're not
putting your bones under
pressure yeah now that's because you
could argue well you know running is
good too which it is and you can say
swimming good too oh that's good too
but you got to put weight on your body
you got to put resistance on your body
to make your bones stronger yeah
yeah
yeah and that's the
the point i think overall that i get
from that so the beginning of what
you're essentially saying is
all kind of exercise has its like
major by the way when you compare it to
no exercise all exercises have major
benefits major they're all different
though so good
so good uh all right so if you're
working out which you are you probably
need some some fuel for you get some
jocko chocofuel jackalful.com
you can get protein
you know you could get protein from a
lot of places you get it from steak
recommended chicken recommended sushi if
you're echo charles yes sir right yeah
what percentage of protein do you get
from sushi like 70
and the other 30 is malk
i would literally say like literally
probably like 50 percent not recently
not but overall you've made sushi at
your house ever no you just have
do you know do they know your order
already do you order the same thing all
the time yes for your whole family
everyone's getting everything like
everyone's getting the same cereal
the charles residence we need our food
sarah goes variable literally like
you're i i see your face and you're kind
of making a joke but i mean kind of no
no i'm being serious
the answer is yes yeah in fact
i call the place because there's a place
literally walking distance from you guys
they got caller id yep i'll there's
let's say hi
no it's not in the oh it's getting cut
wrong yeah sure oh yeah i'll call
they'll be like hi echo how are you
that's it that's how they answer the
phone yeah then i'll be like i want this
i gotta say my order and she already
knows boom boom boom yes how much does
the cost
um it depends so some days they're
closed or they close late so if i or
they close at like 9 30 and there's
another place that closes at
midnight so i'll get it delivered i mean
that one's way more that was like a
hundred bucks per just for me
yeah
how about at the rip for the whole
family no how about just you at the
regular spot oh like 60 60 so
okay that's a good deal given given like
what i get they have good prices over
there cocky sushi cheers that's good
well you're probably gonna need some
milk to wash that down yes sir to get
the sweetness because sushi's not sweet
right is it no sir it is not sweet
you can get some mochi ice cream
afterwards i don't like mochi ice cream
dang bro i don't like that it tastes
like um it tastes like uncooked you know
bread around oh what do they call that
what do they call
they taste like uncooked bread wrapped
around a piece of ice cream who made
that up right
who made that up right
what makes it funny is how accurate you
can are it is right in a way like if you
look at a certain way because it is
essentially like a dough that's right
uncooked but it's like rice dough like
it's a it's mochi that's right you know
what mochi is have you ever had mochi
just mochi you know that wrapping that
you're talking about it's just that
it tastes good right in hawaii you can
get it oh man it's the best but my
family was like somehow amped about
mochi and so they got me amped they got
me hyped this was four years ago oh you
know we'll get this dessert like we had
to go somewhere to get it right yeah so
we get in the car we go we're going to
get mochi
get mine and
like i don't think mine's cooked
because it doesn't taste good right it
tastes like dough like you said it's
dough is it mochi ice cream yeah there's
yeah then there's there's ice cream in
the middle of it but you wrap it up he
said what's the point yeah why don't you
do that why would you do that you are
right because it's not that sweet either
so you're like oh i feel like my snack
no all right it's not so anyway all
right so if you're not into mochi ice
cream and you want because much ice
cream's just ice cream really so that's
not healthy milk on the other hand
healthy way more protein than mochi
emotions doesn't smell like dough it
doesn't taste like dry flour
is it
odd that i'm like
there's a tiny tiny part of me that's
kind of insulted that you don't like
mochi or mochi ice cream it's like i'm
like
you ever have that feeling or it's like
one time okay so i'm a picky eater right
i understand i'm a picky eater i don't
like a bunch of different foods
i was out with my wife one time this
would no she wasn't my wife she was just
a girl that i had met but i was kind of
into her like a lot right oh yeah but
anyway you're talking about your current
wife currently yes my current wife back
then
but we were going out and she wanted me
to try something something i knew i
didn't like i think it was yogurt
but not yogurt you know i'm an american
i'm an american that grew up in the 80s
so so yogurt to me was a freaking dan
and yogurt you know filled with sugar
and blueberries
on like sauce
like those things those things are good
because they're filled with sugar so but
this was we were we were overseas
and i had
already made the mistake of thinking
that yogurt overseas equated to uh dan
and sugar filled yogurt that i ate when
i was 12 years old and ate nine of them
because they tasted good but i realized
that when other people ate yogurt it was
just this weird tasting whatever with
weird cucumbers in it or something
so anyways my my
wife who wasn't my wife yet she's oh
trump she's from england so she's all
nice or whatever oh try this and i go oh
no it's okay i don't really like that
she goes no just try it she's she had
the same attitude that you're implying
right now like she was kind of mad yeah
as if you know
as if you were saying oh i don't you
don't like air what do you mean you
don't like air of course you like air
she's like oh no just try it's just it's
yogurt it's good i go no i don't know
what i like
you know
just try it
and she started escalating kind of
imposed it sometimes okay you know i
take a little spoonful
it's freaking disgusting
i knew it was
i mean
it was you know so so so mochi whatever
ice cream isn't that bad
yeah i can stomach it but i'm not gonna
make an effort to eat it now milk i will
make effort to eat
molca's you you get that hey i will do
what it takes to get some mole cup in
here yeah i last night had a milkshake
double
with a ham it wasn't hammer's turkey
sandwich boom that's a full what up
that's a that's a pleasurable scenario
mine was the basic milkshake by the way
what's basic just the milk it was
lactose free milk okay because i had it
for some other stuff i was making and
just regular milk that's it no no banana
no nothing but you got that little sammy
on and then you put down that mulch
that's a quality scenario right there
you're good to go oh yeah
yeah and it was like no matter if i was
into the extra protein at the time and i
was but even if i wasn't it's like kind
of like a cool little
like a dessert you know
get the drinks at wawa you can get all
of it at vitamin shop appreciated go to
originusa.com
we got some cool stuff for sale there
boots
jeans
t-shirts
most important jiu-jitsu geese yeah i
trained some i trained some
too up
at
paragon san luis obispo paragon slow
it's so cool man you go anywhere right
now and there's jiu jitsu and the people
are awesome everyone's cool
it's just freaking legit great class
but bunch of awesome people there
so
and you know you get you know what's
interesting bro a lot of a lot of origin
geez out there a lot of origin geese out
there people want to buy origin geese
yeah because they know that they're made
in america
bro i saw uh uh
i don't know if what do you call it a
mini doc it is video
about like american manufacturing or it
was about manufacturing and they were
just it was talking about kind of the
history of it or whatever and the
reasons that
you know whether it be china or all
these but like it's kind of like they
they kind of have to do the
manufacturing for all these different
reasons and it depends on the product
and all this stuff right but they kind
of have to do it otherwise it's kind of
like that was kind of the storyline
but then there were there are a little a
few exceptions in there that they didn't
go specific on but they were let's just
like china's doing this this this
because of this and to do it anywhere
else it's like it's it's just
unrealistic you know kind of a thing
but then all the exceptions when i kind
of like deduced all the exceptions i was
like oh wait that's why origen can do
all this stuff they do have to make
certain sacrifices but with the
sacrifices comes like more basically the
detriments that that places like china
or whatever they call what do they call
it affordable labor
affordable
it's freaking slave labor bro yeah
um
it's kind of like that for example but
here you get
basically each laborer or whatever they
have like actual quality of life
that reflects
on the end product kind of a thing so
anyway you can kind of go down the line
and be like oh i see but here's the
thing at the end of the day my point is
like what they do is like dang that's
kind of
not kind of that's like
that's a very unique thing that they're
doing who's they or origin usa yes us
us this is a very unique thing that we
are doing
so yeah go to
originusa.com for that we also have a
store
it's called the echo
store that's the forwarding
jocko store.com
so you can write that's where you can
get your shirts and your merch it's good
stuff on there too by the way it's not
just like cheap
you know
what do you call low cost uh to the
lowest common denominator uh lowest
bidder what is that expression it's not
either whatever the expression is it's
not that it's quality good stuff you
want to represent and represent hard and
look good and feel good by the way yes
you can get all kinds of good stuff on
there jacquelinestore.com uh subscribe
to the podcast
and also check out jacounderground.com
it's very interesting what's happening
right now in the world yep and
[Music]
look yeah there's a war going on right
now an insane war right a
war that the likes of which we have not
seen
in a long time in in ukraine
so that's happening but meanwhile you
got
just crazy things happening all around
the world you got censorship happy you
got people shutting down
websites shutting down
people from speaking
you've got control media influenced by
the government influenced by big tech
all in one it's it's crazy stuff
happening right now jackonground.com if
you want to help about where we have a
little
little bastion of our own
where if we need to retreat to
to rebuild we'll be in there
jockowinderground.com if you want to
support that you can check that out we
have a youtube channel
we have a the origin usa has a youtube
channel so check both those out
um what else we got psychological
warfare
since a little album the wednesday you
can uh you can download this album if
you and if you have moments of weakness
it's basically jocko telling you how to
get past those moments a week it's very
helpful on those moments trust me even
if you don't have a lot of them you can
just have one
reduce it to zero maybe you're addicted
to mochi
uh flipsidecanvas.com dakota meyer my
brother is got cool stuff to hang on
your wall i've written a bunch of books
check them out if you want to especially
check out the warrior kid books
that's where you can have a huge impact
you can have a huge impact on a kid's
life just by
getting
that kid
those books
so check that out
echelonfront.com
it's our leadership consultancy
we have an event called the muster we
have one in dallas it's sold out
so sorry about that but we have other
ones you can check that out
we have
online training at extreme ownership
academy extremeownership.com
a bunch of information on there about
being a leader and about being a human
being
it'll help you with everything in your
life so check that out if you want to
help out service members active and
retired you want to help with their
families gold star families check out
mark lee's mom mama lee she's got an
incredible charity organization
go to
americasmightywarriors.org if you want
to help out also check out heroes and
horses micah fink
he's got a bunch of awesome stuff going
on once again
to contact
joe piersante his his website is joe
p
dot us
and he's also got a linkedin
account which is joe piersante and he's
got
a
facebook as well which is joe piersante
i
b
f
b f pro pro yep international
bodybuilding federation pro so
check that out as far as echo and i go
we're both on twitter we're both on the
ground we're both on facebook
echoes that echo charles i'm at
jacqueline but you know
just look out
because you're you're you step in there
you're going to be fighting the
algorithm because that's what's
happening you're going to be fighting
the algorithm so be careful when you
step in there thanks once again to joe
piersante
for coming on
um
for just setting an incredible example
of
tenacity and of perseverance
and i mean just him saying
him putting
the perspective of becoming blind
becoming wounded becoming blind
and and he said yeah no you can't no use
crying over spilled milk
to put those two in the same sentence
and actually behave that way
truly inspiring person so thank you joe
for coming on and thanks to all the
military personnel out there around the
world
that stand up and fight for freedom and
liberty
and i know there's some of you out out
there right now that are truly standing
up and fighting for freedom and liberty
so thank you for holding the line and
thanks to our police and law enforcement
and tonight especially
thanks to the dea the drug enforcement
agency
men like joe piersante that are out
there trying to protect us all
from the evil of drugs
and the violent crime that it produces
and also thanks to firefighters
paramedics
border patrol emts dispatchers
correctional officers secret service all
the first responders
thank you for your service here on the
home front
[Music]
and
everyone else out there
well what excuses do you possibly have
right if someone like joe can go through
what he's gone through can suffer what
he suffered
can still go out there every day and get
after it and and you know he said
something
he said you can't make a case sitting
behind a desk
and that's some pretty good advice not
just for law enforcement but for life
what you have to do is go out there
every single day
and get after it
until next time
this is echo and jocko